[Musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement Francis
Perin ?
Bonsoir, merci beaucoup. Euh je suis euh
directeur de recherche à LIRIS,
l'Institut de relations interalees et
stratégique qui est basé à Paris et
chercheur associé au policy center
forvenue South qui est basé à Rabat au
Maroc et je travaille sur les questions
énergétiques.
Nicolas Millant.
Euh moi je suis ingénieur de formation.
J'ai fait l'école des travaux publics et
le MIT. J'ai travaillé pendant 15 ans
dans un cabinet de conseil euh sur
notamment le transport et la mobilité.
Et depuis 2018, je suis à mon compte, je
travaille sur les voitures électriques.
Tous les mois, je publie un rapport sur
les ventes de voitures électriques dans
le monde. Je j'ai travaillé 4 ans avec
France Stratégie comme conseiller
scientifique, mais ça s'est arrêté en
décembre et je travaille aussi un peu
avec ma femme qui a lancé une entreprise
de culottes menstruel en France et donc
je contribue à la réindustrialisation du
pays. et je fais partie aussi de Aspo
France, l'association pour l'étude du
pic pétrolier et gazier depuis un
certain nombre d'années.
Alors messieurs, on a décidé de vous
faire venir ce soir pour parler énergie
comme vous avez pu le remarquer Francis,
on est très content de vous recevoir
aussi parce que ça fait au moins 5 6 ans
que vous étiez pas passés. Euh la
communauté vous adore, très pédagogique,
de bonnes informations. Euh ils nous ont
réclamé Francis.
Merci beaucoup. Et et donc bah surtout
en ce moment donc Francis la première
question
l'énergie on va où ? Les classes
moyennes vont continuer à se prendre un
choc énergétique important ? Est-ce que
c'est un problème d'approvisionnement ?
C'est un problème de pipeline ? C'est un
problème géopolitique ? Est-ce que c'est
un problème de ressources ? Est-ce que
c'est la comme dirait Sgolen Royade la
finitude des ressources ? Francis,
est-ce que vous pouvez nous est-ce que
vous pouvez nous éclairer ? Alors
effectivement euh la hausse des prix de
l'énergie euh notamment du pétrole et du
gaz naturel est une réalité mondiale
depuis pas seulement le début 2022, pas
seulement depuis le 24 février 2022,
mais depuis 2021.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en 2021 ? Une
chose très simple après l'année 2020 que
personne n'est sur le point d'oublier
marqué par la pandémie de Covid-19 le
début et sa phase la plus aigue et une
récession économique mondiale. En 2021,
l'économie mondiale repart à plein
régime.
Une croissance économique de l'ordre de
environ 6 %. Et un monde qui repart à
plein régime va évidemment consommer
plus d'énergie. dont plus de pétrole et
de gaz et les prix repartent à la
hausse. L'offre euh mondiale, la
production va tirer un petit peu la pâte
par rapport à ce redémarrage euh très
fort de la consommation lié à une forte
reprise économique mondiale. On est avec
des stocks pétroliers et gaziers assez
bas, notamment en Europe. Donc quand sur
un marché vous avez une demande qui
augmente fortement, une offre qui traîne
un peu la patte et des stocks qui sont
bas, en général ça fait des prix qui
augmentent et c'est pas valable
seulement que pour le pétrole et le gaz.
Et là-dessus, vous ajoutez un certain
nombre d'éléments géopolitiques
sur lesquels nous reviendrons
certainement dans le cours de notre
discussion. Donc ça c'est 2021, automne
2021, le début de la crise
russo-rainienne
qui va précéder la guerre. Évidemment,
ça fait monter encore plus les prix du
pétrole et du gaz parce que beaucoup de
gens se rendent compte que on va vers
une guerre, même si ce n'était pas une
certitude à l'automne. Et puis le 24
février 2021, le début de la guerre, le
prix du pétrole de qualité Brent produit
en mer du Nord, donc en Europe, passe le
seuil des 100 dollars par baril pour la
première fois depuis 2014. Donc son
niveau le plus élevé depuis depuis 8
ans, il était déjà élevé, il était déjà
au-dessus de 90 dollars hein le 23
février. Donc il était pas à 50 dollars
par baril mais il passe le seuil
hautement symbolique des 100 dollars par
baril et depuis le début de la guerre,
on va monter jusqu'à un pic de 139
dollars par baril avant de retomber à
100, de remonter à plus de 120, de
retomber voilà mais en tout cas on est
depuis au-dessus de 100 dollars par
baril pour le prix du brand. le prix du
gaz naturel va battre tous les records
sur le marché européen. Euh donc, on a
une succession d'événements, d'abord des
facteur économique en 2021, notamment
lié à la reprise économique mondiale
post 2020, puis un certain nombre
d'événements géopolitiques dont la crise
russo-rainienne à l'automne 2021.
Évidemment, début 2022, février 2022, la
guerre en Ukraine qui va encore pousser
les prix à des sommets pas record pour
le pétrole, record pour le gaz naturel,
mais très élevé pour le pétrole.
Nicolas, est-ce queon peut amander
compléter euh ce que vient de dire euh
Francis ?
Ouais, je pense qu'il faut, comme le
disait bien Francis, il y avait déjà une
contrainte avant les événements récents
en Ukraine
sur le pétrole mais surtout sur sur le
gaz. notamment en Europe parce que quand
on parle d'un pétrole qui augmente de 30
40 %, on parle d'un prix du gaz qui est
multiplié par 6 ou 7. Donc c'est
vraiment un autre de grandeur. Et le
problème qu'on a en Europe avec ce prix
du gaz, cette augmentation qui est liée
au fait que quand on est arrivé dans
l'hiver, le stockage en Europe était des
niveaux assez bass. On voyait pas le gaz
arriver de arriver de Russie et donc on
avait peur d'avoir des contraintes, des
coupures au cours de l'hiver. Et le
problème qu'on a en Europe, c'est que
les prix de l'électricité
sont indexés sur le prix du gaz. Donc
quand vous avez un gaz à 350 du MWh, ça
fait un prix d'électricité au double
puisque on a un rendement de 50 % donc
700 € du MWh. Euh et ça ça correspond à
10 fois le prix que vous payez
aujourd'hui. Et donc ça va impacter
beaucoup les industriels notamment parce
que vous vous êtes protégé par un
contrat à long terme mais c'est pas le
cas protéger
pour l'instant avec le avec l'argent
magique d'Emmanuel Macron mais c'est pas
le cas des des industriels et ça va
impacter encore d'autres choses comme
par exemple euh le le prix des engrais.
Pourquoi ? Parce que le prix des engrais
c'est formé à base d'hydrogène qui
lui-même est formé à base de gaz
naturel, de reformage de gaz naturel.
Donc on va peut-être moins produire
d'anglais. Ça va aussi impacter le prix
du diesel parce que quand on raffine euh
du pétrole pour fabriquer du diesel, on
le on le désulfurise et on utilise pour
ça de l'hydrogène. Et cet hydrogène, il
est pas encore vert. Malheureusement, il
est gris puisqu'il est fabriqué avec du
gaz naturel. Et c'est aussi la raison
pour laquelle récemment les raffineurs
ont produit moins de diesel parce que le
gaz naturel était plus cher et qu'on est
donc sur le diesel à des niveaux de
stock qu'on doit remonter à 2008 il me
semble en Europe pour avoir des niveaux
aussi bas et qu'aujourd'hui même si peu
de gens en parlent la contrainte qui
pourra arriver dans les prochaines
semaines en Europe c'est une contrainte
sur l'approvisionnement en diesen
peut-être je voulais juste souligner un
point c'est que au moment où nous
parlons et Il faut préciser au moment où
nous parlons parce que nous sommes dans
une guerre donc dans un maximum
d'incertitude géopolitique,
il n'y a pas encore entre guillemets de
pénurie de pétrole et de gaz naturel.
Pourquoi entre guillemets encore ?
Alors parce que encore supposerait que
je puisse prédire l'avenir et ma boule
de cristal, je l'ai laissé à la maison
donc ce sera pour la prochaine émission.
Mais
c'est pas vrai, vous n'avez pas de bou
cristal.
C'est je n'espérais pas être démasqué
publiquement à Finkerview. Donc je ne
sais pas si je reviendrai mais donc non
voilà il n'y a pas de pénurie de
pétrolet de gaz. Il y a des tensions sur
le marché pétrolier et gazier depuis
2021 et aggravé par la situation
actuelle. Mais sur les marchés
pétroliers gaziers où on passe son temps
à anticiper ce qui pourrait se passer
conditionnel, on se dit une guerre en
Ukraine, la Russie impliquée, la Russie
qui est le deuxè producteur mondial de
gaz naturel, le premier producteur
mondial le pardon le deuxème producteur
mondial de pétrole, le premier
exportateur mondial de gaz, le premier
exportateur mondial pétrole plus produit
raffiné. Donc, il va y avoir un
problème. Donc, les prix augmentent euh
de façon très forte pour des raisons
géopolitiques et des incertitudes
géopolitique sans que au moment où nous
parlions, il y ait en terme physique une
pénurie en terme du fait que la demande
de pétrolet de gaz serait supérieure à
l'offre. Ça peut venir, ce n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui.
Alors, ça peut venir comment ? Dans
quelle proportion ? Quelle vélo ? Euh
qu'est-ce que votre boule magique dit ?
Alors euh trois scénarios possibles
prenons le gaz naturel qui est
particulièrement important. Les deux
sont importants évidemment pétrole et
gaz naturel. Cela va de soi. Mais le gaz
naturel est particulièrement lié à la
guerre en Ukraine parce que l'Ukraine
est l'une des voies de transit d'une
partie du gaz russe allant vers l'Union
européenne.
Ils prennent 2 milliards de de dollars
de transit. C'est ça.
C'est 2 à 3 milliards de dollars en
fonction du niveau des prix chaque année
en terme de droits de transit. Donc
c'est important évidemment pour pour
l'Ukraine et c'est important bien sûr
pour l'Union européenne et pour la
Russie qui est un pays exportateur.
Ils ont arrêté là ou pas ?
Non. Au moment où nous parlons, le gaz
russe, une partie du gaz russe continue
à transiter par l'Ukraine, pays en
guerre pour arriver sur les marchés
européens.
Et les Russes payent toujours ou pas
? Alors ça, je ne le sais pas. C'est une
très bonne question. Normalement, ils
doivent évidemment bien sûr euh je ne
suis pas sûr de ce qu'ils font euh vu
qu'ils sont en guerre contre l'Ukraine
dans les derniers jours ou euh mais
normalement ils doivent payer puisque le
gaz continue à transiter. Ce gaz n'a pas
été interrompu.
Alors non seulement il a d'ailleurs
elles n'ont pas été arrêtées
oui
mais elles ont augmenté. Les livraisons
de gaz russes à l'Europe depuis
l'invasion ont augmenté que ce soit par
le pipeline qui passe par l'Ukraine ou
par ou par Nordstream qui part qui passe
sous la mer Baltique.
Il y a en fait quatre voies actuelles
pour la Russie pour acheminer son gaz
vers l'Europe. Il y a donc celle dont
nous parlons bien sûr lié à la guerre
donc Russie-Ukraine Union européenne. Il
y a Russie Biélorussie Union européenne.
une deuxième route d'exportation. Il y a
le Nordstream qui évoquait Nicolas, donc
c'est Russie, mer Baltique, Allemagne et
une 4e voix, c'est le Turkstream,
Russie, mer noire, Turquie et ensuite
Union européenne. Et il devait y en
avoir une 5è, le Nordstream 2 avec le
même tracé que le Nordstream 1, donc
Russie, Mer Baltique, Allemagne. Sauf
que celui-ci en lien direct avec la
guerre en Ukraine ou juste avant la
guerre en Ukraine n'a pas eu sa
validation pour entrer en service en
2022 de la part des autorités
allemandes. Mais donc le gaz continue à
couler. Mais les scénarios
premier scénario, la Russie coupe le
robinet du gaz.
Peu vraisemblable. Ce scénario fait peur
aux Européens puisque nous sommes
fortement dépendants du gaz russe. Euh
2020-2021, le gaz russe, c'est 45 % des
importations de gaz de l'Union
européenne. Donc forcément, on n'est pas
très tranquille. Mais la Russie n'a pas
intérêt à couper le robinet du gaz
puisque c'est une source importante de
recette d'exportation.
Deuxème scénario, nous parlons d'une
guerre donc d'opération militaire. On
tire des missiles et cetera. À quel
moment il y en a un qui tombe sur un gaz
auoduc ? il ne sera pas visé
délibérément mais ça peut arriver. Ce
serait pas la première fois dans une
guerre qu'on vise quelque chose et que
le missile tombe à côté. 3è scénario,
les Européens pour sanctionner la Russie
décident de se priver délibérément d'une
partie du gaz et du pétrole exporté par
la Russie. Et ce troisème scénario, on y
arrive en terme de réalité, pas
aujourd'hui, pas à court terme, mais
dans une optique de moyen terme. Donc
sont les trois scénarios possibles par
rapport au gaz. Et pour le 3è, il touche
également gaz et pétrole puisque l'Union
européenne a disé pour la première fois
dans son histoire de dire à moyen terme,
ça c'est l'orientation politique, moyen
terme vouant dire en gros 5 ans 2027, on
veut se passer complètement du pétrole
et du gaz russe, ce qui est une première
dans l'histoire des relations
énergétiques Union européenne Russie.
Alors c'est pas fait mais l'orientation
politique a été adoptée par les 27
membres de l'UE Union européenne à
l'unanimité.
Mais entre vous et moi, c'est pas un
petit peu des déclarations
incantatoires,
c'est pas un petit peu euh s'agiter euh
ou bouger agiter les bras pour dire "On
est en train de faire quelque chose."
Parce que se passer de 47 % de notre
approvisionnement gaz naturel euh d'ici
2037 27
27,
c'est ça fait
très ambitieux.
C'est très très ambitieux, non ?
Très ambitieux.
Euh le gaz donc part du gaz russe dans
les importations européennes Union
européenne
202021, on est à peu près à 45 %. On a
la même proportion pour le charbon et
pour pétrole produit raffiné, on est à
25 30 %. Donc c'est très ambitieux
particulièrement pour le gaz naturel.
Alors est-ce que c'est de la
gesticulation politique uniquement ? de
la gesticulation politique au moins en
partie, ça c'est clair. C'est pour dire
pour frapper le régime de Vladimir
Poutine et l'économie russe, qu'est-ce
qu'on vise ? Qu'est-ce qui est au cœur
de l'économie russe ? Les hydrocarbures,
pétrole et gaz naturel. Pétrole et gaz,
c'est 60 % des recettes d'exportation de
la Russie. Donc si on veut faire mal à
l'économie russe, il est difficile de
dire je ne touche pas au pétrole et au
gaz naturel. On voit la logique du
raisonnement. Ensuite, pour l'Union
européenne qui est indépendante, c'est
pas évident et c'est pour ça qu'on dit
on ne le fait pas tout de suite comme le
font les États-Unis. Le 8 mars, Joe
Biden ditembargo
je n'apporte plus de pétrole russe,
produits pétroliers russes, gaz russe,
charbon russe. Il peut le faire parce
qu'il est un grand producteur d'énergie
fossile et il peut le faire parce qu'il
n'est il n'est que très peu dépendant de
la Russie. L'Union européenne ne produit
pas beaucoup d'énergie fossile et est
très dépendant de la Russie. Donc le
calendrier ne peut pas être le même. Et
donc l'Union européenne dit à court
terme 1 an, on va commencer à réduire
significativement nos importation de gaz
russe et dans 5 ans, on n'apportera plus
ni pétrole ni charbon russe.
Bon courage les gars.
Sachant que sachant que c'est pas parce
que l'Europe n'apporte pas de pétrole et
de gaz russe que la Russie va être
impactée puisque elle le vendra
ailleurs. Elle pourra le vendre à
l'Inde, elle pourra le vendre à la
Chine, au Japon et elle pourra le vendre
à la Corée du Sud. Donc on est entré
c'est une chose enfin l'impact sur
l'impact sur la Russie n'est pas n'est
pas forcément évident. l'impact sur nous
va être très fort parce que finalement
on a vu des dirigeants qui sont en train
de nous proposer après le Green Deal de
la croissance verte ou le mot pétrole ne
doit pas apparaître une seule fois un
menu de décroissance à marche forcée
raison de une douche froide par semaine
de baisser sa vitesse sur l'autoroute.
On avait jamais entendu ces mots-là dans
dans les mots des dirigeants et
finalement on a l'impression qu'avec ce
conflit ils ont découvert le mot pétrole
et le mot gaz. Et cependant, Nicolas et
euh peut-être
la substitution
Asie qui va remplacer l'Europe. Pas
simple.
Euh pas simple parce que dans l'Asie, tu
as évoqué de grands pays évidemment
consommateurs d'hydrocarbure.
Euh Chine, Inde, Japon, Corée du Sud.
Japon, Corée du Sud, pays très proche
des États-Unis. Donc les pressions
américaines sur ces deux pays pour qu'il
n'aident pas à la Russie à contourner
les sanctions sont très fortes. Je vois
mal les dirigeants japonais et coréens
euh dire si je puis dire niet aux
États-Unis. Donc ça à mon avis c'est
fermé. Il reste évidemment la Chine et
l'Inde qui n'ont pas la même relation
avec les États-Unis. Par contre, on le
voit bien actuellement, les dirigeants
chinois sont d'une prudence de su hein.
Ils ne tiennent pas à tomber sous le cou
des sanctions notamment américaines. Et
les banques d'État chinoises et les
compagnies pétrolières chinoises ne sont
pas forcément incité par le pouvoir
chinois à se précipiter sur le pétrole
et le gaz russe. Ils vont en profiter
parce que la Russie va casser les prix
pour trouver des débouchés. Donc, ils
feront quelques bonnes affaires. Et puis
par ailleurs, un pays comme la Chine qui
est un énorme importateur, premier
importateur mondial de pétrole et
importateur croissant de gaz naturel qui
deviendra à terme le premier. Sa logique
c'est quoi ? C'est la diversification.
Quand on importe énormément d'énergie,
on n' pas envie de dépendre trop d'un
seul fournisseur, que ce soit la Russie
ou un autre. Donc la Russie là la Chine
pardon, elle importe du gaz de la
Russie. Elle va continuer à le faire et
faire quelques bonnes affaires en
profitant d'un gaz bradé. Mais elle va
continuer à apporter du gaz naturel
liquéfié venant des États-Unis, du gaz
naturel liquéfié venant de l'Australie,
du gaz naturel liquéfié venant du
Moyen-Orient, plus d'autres pays
asiatiques. Elle ne va pas sacrifier sa
diversification qui quelque chose de
parfaitement raisonnable en terme
d'énergie
pour se précipiter vers le gaz russe
pour sauver la Russie face aux sanctions
occidentales.
Oui. Sachant qu'en plus sur le gaz, on n
pas forcément encore les capacités de
pipeline pour envoyer la production qui
part en Europe vers la Chine, même si on
des capacités de gaz naturel liquéfié
aussi à Yam.
Quand on voit Joe Biden dire "Vous
inquiétez pas les Européens,
on a négocié avec le Qatar, le Qatar il
va vous donner du gaz pas cher et et en
quantité." Alors pas cher, on sait pas.
Pas cher, non ?
Non.
Et et quand on voit le Qatar répondre,
dire "Ou là là là, nos capacités à faire
croître nos exportations sont limitées."
Oui.
Francis, qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Alors,
vous avez évoqué
les volumes, les quantités et les prix.
Écartons tout de suite la question prix.
Dans un monde où les prix du gaz, les
prix du pétrole, les prix d'énergie sont
chers, personne ne nous fera de cadeau
en cassant les prix sur le pétrole et le
gaz qu'on va vendre à l'Union
européenne. Tous les pays exportateurs
vont vouloir profiter de la situation
actuelle et vendre au prix du marché.
Donc on payera ça cher, c'est clair,
net, précis. Une petite idée du cher
euh cher, ça veut dire très cher en ce
moment. Euh parce que justement les prix
qui étaient déjà élevés depuis 2021 euh
ont sont montés dans la stratosphère
avec depuis le début de la guerre en
Ukraine et aucun pays exportateur ne va
brader son gaz pour les beaux yeux de
l'Union européenne. Mais il faudra payer
l'addition, c'est clair, parce que on
n'est pas prêt à affronter une pénurie
d'énergie. Aucun gouvernement et aucune
grande puissance industrielle ne va
affronter ça pour sa population, son
économie, son industrie et cetera. Donc
on payera le prix qu'il faut. Mais
encore faut-il trouver les quantités ?
Alors les quantités, je reviens à la
question sur le Qatar.
Euh le Qatar a dit "Moi, je veux bien
aider les Européens euh mais j'ai des
contrats. J'ai signé des contrats avec
des pays européens et avec des pays
asiatiques. Je vais pas priver mes
clients asiatiques de gaz pour l'envoyer
en Europe. J'ai signé des contrats, je
vais respecter les contrats raisonnement
parfaitement indiscutable."
À ce moment-là, les Américains ont dit
"On va commencer une partie de billard à
trois bandes. On négocie avec le Qatar,
avec le Japon, avec la Corée du Sud. et
Japonais et coréens ont dit avec une
forte incitation américaine, on pourrait
si l'Europe était en situation de crise
gazière renoncer à une partie de nos
approvisionnements temporairement bien
sûr sous certaines conditions pour que
certaines cargaisons de gaz qui devaient
aller vers l'Asie, gaz naturel liquéfié
transporté par bateau, aille vers
l'Europe. Et à ces conditions là, le
Qatar a dit "Bon ben, si mes clients
sont d'accord, moi j'ai pas de
problème." Mais le Qatar a ajouté une
condition. Si j'envoie plus de gaz vers
l'Europe parce que vous en avez besoin,
c'est pas pour ce que certains petits
malins en Europe réexportent le gazari
en profitant de prix élevés du gaz pour
le vendre ailleurs. Si je vous vends
plus de gaz, il reste en Europe, ce qui
paraît une condition qui est pas
absurde. Les Européens ont dit tout de
suite oui. Évidemment, ils allaient pas
dire non. Donc le Qatar peut apporter
une partie de la solution. Les
États-Unis viennent de signer un accord
avec l'Union européenne pour exporter
plus de gaz naturel liquéfiés vers
l'Europe. Euh, il y a des négociation
avec l'Australie, c'est loin mais après
tout, si on a besoin de gaz, on ira le
chercher partout, même sur une autre
planète. Il y a des discussions en
Afrique avec l'Algérie, l'Égypte, le
Nigéria. Il y a des discussions en
Europe avec la Norvège, l'Azerbaïdjan.
L'idée c'est que aucun pays prisolément,
ni États-Unis, ni Qatar, ni encore moins
les autres ne sera la solution. que
chacun de ces différents pays peut être
une partie de la solution et en
additionnant des parties, on peut avoir
la solution. C'est ça l'idée général.
Ouais. Sur sur le coût du gaz russe, les
sanctions, je crois que leur budget leur
budget tient quand le baril est à 54
dollars. Donc il va falloir faire de
beaucoup plus de sanctions s'ils veulent
vraiment toucher le le l'économie russe
jusqu'à attaquer leur budget.
Juste sur le gaz de chiste. Donc Joe
Biden, bon
débarque avec des contrats de gaz de
chiste réputé écossi en Europe.
Comment on fait pour décompresser ce gaz
? Il y a combien de terminaux ? Il y a
je crois il y a que trois terminaux en
France pour quatre.
On est pas mal placé en France. Cette
capacité de décompression de gaz de
chiste, ça équivaut à combien
en équivalent
volumétrique de de gaz à décompresser ?
Est-ce que ça va couvrir notre
dépendance ?
En gros, ce qu'il faut avoir en tête sur
les volumes de les volumes consommés en
Europe, on est à peu près à 400
milliards de mètres cus contrôle de
Francis. 400 milliards de mètres cb. La
Russie c'est un peu plus de 150
milliards de mètres c
et cette année ou l'an dernier en
Europe, on a apporté 20 milliards de
mètres cubes des États-Unis. Donc ça
couvre 5 % de la consommation. Et là la
discussion qu'il y a eu et l'accord
signé c'est de dire on va l'augmenter de
15 milliards de m c dans c é 25
milliards de m³. on va l'augmenter de
15, donc on va passer à 40 et à moyen
terme à horizon 2030, on va monter à 50
milliards de m c où l'Europe s'engage à
prendre à ce qu'il y ait la demande pour
50 milliards de m cb donc ce qui fait un
peu plus de 10 % de notre consommation.
Bien et bien comme vous l'avez rappelé,
c'est une exploitation qui est interdite
chez nous. Qui est interdite. Alors
c'est vrai qu'on est champion du monde
pour délocaliser la pollution. Donc là,
on est très content et d'ailleurs, on en
apporte déjà,
c'est pas nouveau. Depuis quelques
années par NJ,
on se chauffe déjà au gaz de chiste et
c'est le fameux le fameux double
standard français. Faites ce que je dis,
pas ce que je fais. On aurait pu
imaginer quit à en apporter plus. On
s'était même interdit non seulement de
l'exploiter mais même de l'explorer,
c'est-à-dire de regarder si on aurait en
France des réserves en sous-sol qui
seraient exploitable. probablement
d'ailleurs dans des meilleures
conditions qu'aux États-Unis puisqu'on a
quand même les euh les euh les normes
environnementales les plus élevées. Je
rappelle qu'aux États-Unis, le
développement du pétrole et du gaz non
conventionnel à partir de à partir de
2005 se fait parce que George Bouche
exempte euh notamment les entreprises
pétrolières des lois de protection sur
l'air et sur l'eau, ce qui rend les
choses plus faciles entre guillemets.
Je reviens sur le chiffre cité par
Nicolas à juste titre. 50 milliards de
mètres cubes euh de gaz naturel liquéfié
américain pouvant arriver en Europe dans
les dans un certain nombre d'années. Euh
ce serait à peu près un/ers
des importations de gaz russes
transporté par gazoduc puisqu'on était
sur 155 milliards de m c par an. Donc
quand on fait la proportion, c'est pas
ridicule. C'est pas c'est pas évidemment
c'est un tiers, ça veut dire qu'il reste
2 tiers.
Là on est dans l'hypothèse où le gaz
russe disparaît. Hypothèse 2027 mais
commencer par un accord avec les
États-Unis qui sont aujourd'hui le
premier exportateur mondial de gaz
naturel liquéfié. La Russie est le
premier exportateur mondial de gaz.
Le gaz, on l'exporte de deux façons.
Soit sous forme gazeuse dans un gazoduc,
soit sous forme liquéfiée sur un bateau
qui s'appelle un méthagier. Donc pour le
total des exportations de gaz, Russie
premier exportateur mondial. Mais pour
le segment GNL, gaz naturelquéfié, les
États-Unis aujourd'hui sont devenus le
premier exportateur mondial de GNL. Donc
évidemment, l'Union européenne qui a
peur de manquer de gaz compte tenu de la
guerre, elle ne pouvait pas ne pas se
tourner pas uniquement mais commencer
par se tourner par son allié quand même
qui en plus est une le premier
producteur mondial de gaz naturel et le
premier exportateur mondial de gaz
naturel liquéfié pour couvrir une partie
de ses besoins. Ensuite, évidemment,
c'est le début du travail, ce n'est pas
la fin. Alors, je suis pas complètement
d'accord avec ton chiffre
puisqueeffectivement 50 milliards, c'est
1/3 des euh des euh des exportation
russes,
mais on en a déjà 25
aujourd'hui. Donc l'incrément, c'est 25.
Là, on parle de quantité supplémentaire.
Ah moi j'avais compris le total mais
c'est c'est présenté comme des volumes
supplémentaires. C'est un accord
politique. Il faudra voir évidemment
bien sûr regarder de très près les le
détail hein. Le diable est dans des
détails comme diraient nos amis
anglo-saxons. Donc mais c'est plutôt
présenté comme des volumes
supplémentaires par rapport à ce qui
arrive déjà en Europe. Parce que comme
tu l'as rappelé, ce n'est pas en 2022
que l'Union européenne dont la France
ont commencé à apporter du gaz naturel
liquéfié venant des États-Unis qui en
terme de production est effectivement du
gaz non conventionnel qu'on appelle
souvent en France gaz de chiste
en grande partie.
Une question pour vous deux, vous
déciderez qui répondra en premier.
l'état des réserves et des puits russes.
J'ai j'ai eu quelques informations de
gens très bien placé dans la partie et
certains me disent la plupart des puits
de pétrole russe ont été fort n'importe
comment. Donc ça va coûter soit beaucoup
plus cher d'aller chercher la la
ressource ou soit ça va pas pouvoir être
possible. Est-ce que vous avez des
informations qui vont ou qui iraient
dans ce sens ? Moi, je vais parler juste
du pétrole rapidement puisque sur le
gaz, c'est peut-être un peu plus
compliqué. Euh sur le pétrole, le
ministre même de l'énergie russe hein
avait dit que ils étaient
vraisemblablement un maximum de
production euh sur la production de
pétrole russe. Donc, il est possible de
toute façon que d'ici 5 ans euh les
quantités de pétrole à exporter ont
diminué et donc ils auront plus
forcément d'ailleurs autant de quantité
à expé à exporter chez nous. Et ce
phénomène pourrait être accentué si
jamais aujourd'hui euh on avait euh un
embargo sur le pétrole russe qu'il ne
trouvait plus de déboucher, alors on
aurait une contrainte de stockage et une
fois que tous les stockages les soit sur
mer dans les bateaux soit sur terre
serait en pleine capacité, il serait
obligé de fermer certains puits et quand
on ferme un puit quand on le réouvre
après, c'est ça prend du temps et on a
beaucoup de mal à revenir au niveau de
production euh précédent. Donc on en est
on n'est pas dans cette situation mais
ça pourrait être entre guillemets un
accélérateur de pic pétrolier qui est
concrètement la situation actuelle en
Russie un maximum autour de 10 millions
de barils par jour. Francis,
ce que disait Nicolas sur la ce que peut
entraîner la réouverture d'un puit,
effectivement c'est pas une opération
facile. C'est d'autant plus délicat que
la fermeture a été longue
et quand en plus on est en Russie et
notamment en Sibérie, c'est
particulièrement plus compliqué que si
on est dans les déserts de l'Arabie
Saoudite. Donc sur le plan technique,
c'est très clair. Il y a ça peut poser
un problème important sur le gaz. Euh je
pense que en terme de réserve de
potentiel russe, il y a vraiment de la
marche. Leur problème va être de
commercialiser ce gaz face à des
sanctions occidentales et à la volonté
affichée politiquement par l'Union
européenne de renoncer à terme au gaz
russe. Ça c'est un très gros problème
pour eux puisque depuis des dizaines
d'années, l'Europe c'est le principal
marché pour Gazprom, pour le gaz russe.
Le principal marché n'est pas l'Asie.
Euh bien sûr, la Russie vend aussi du
gaz en Asie, mais entre les deux, on
n'est pas au même sur les mêmes
chiffres.
Est-ce que ça toute comparaison gardé,
est-ce que ça ressemble pas euh à
l'Arabie Saoudite quand on nous dit
quand on leur dit "Vous inquiétez pas
les gars, on va passer au 100 %
renouvelable."
C'est-à-dire que ils vont se retrouver
avec leur pétrole sur les bras. Est-ce
que là, en annonçant à la Russie en
2027, votre gaz c'est terminé ? Est-ce
que ça va pas les forcer ? à fournir du
gaz pas cher du tout au Pakistan par
camion par je ne sais pas quoi pour
se sauver du des des menaces sur leur
économie. Est-ce que est-ce que la la
Russie va pas être tentée de faire
augmenter les prix pour faire un petit
trésor de guerre en attendant 2027 ?
Ce qui est clair, c'est que cette guerre
a fait monter les prix du pétrole et du
gaz qui était déjà élevé et maintenant
ils sont encore plus élevés. Donc tous
les pays qui exportent du pétrol et du
gaz profitent économiquement de la
situation. Chaque baril de pétrole que
vous vendez vaut plus de dollars. Chaque
mètre cube de gaz que vous vendez vaut
plus de dollars. Et parmi ces pays
exportateurs de pétrole et de gaz, ceux
qui en plus ont des capacités non
complètement utilisées
ont un deuxième avantage, c'est qu'ils
sont extrêmement courtisés puisque les
Européens parcourent le monde pour dire
qui pourrait demain si besoin était me
vendre plus de pétrole et plus de gaz
naturel. Donc ça les met en position de
force. Il y a la l'effet prix et l'effet
volume pour ceux qui pourraient produire
plus. Donc ça c'est en terme de
géographie, d'économie et de
géopolitique pétrolière et gazière.
C'est important. Et donc un pays comme
l'Arabie Saoudite qui est le 3è
exportateur mondial de pétrole brut mais
le premier exportateur mondial de
pétrole brut évidemment ils sont en
position de force actuellement hein et
d'autres bien sûr. Donc je pense que sur
le gaz le principal problème c'est
vraiment la question des débouchés pour
la Russie c'est pas la question des
réserves. Le pétrole comme l'a dit
Nicolas c'est plus compliqué pour eux.
Euh il il plafonnent hein avant les
réductions décidées par ce qu'on appelle
l'OPEP plus. 23 pays exportateurs de
pétrole dont les 13 pays membre de
l'OPEP plus 10 pays non OPEP. Donc ils
ont un peu baissé pour faire remonter
les prix depuis 2020 mais ils
produisaient en gros 11 millions de
barils de pétrole par jour et
effectivement il disait que ils
pourraient pas forcément aller beaucoup
plus loin. Pour le gaz ils peuvent aller
plus haut mais encore faut-il qu'il y
ait un marché. Et là, ils ont un vrai
problème. Et pour revenir au pétrole,
l'Agence inale de l'énergie, l'AIE, qui
est basé à Paris, euh nous dit "Il se
peut qu'on a un problème dès le mois
d'avril 2022, c'est-à-dire demain."
Pourquoi ?
un certain nombre de sociétés
pétrolières, de sociétés de négo qui
achètent et qui vendent des matières
premières, un certain nombre de banques,
d'institutions financières ont un
problème de réputation actuellement avec
le pétrole russe.
C'est ça.
Et donc entre les sanctions financières,
parce que ces transactions pétrolières,
elles sont financées par des banques.
Euh ça coûte cher. Donc entre les
problèmes liés aux sanctions
financières, les problèmes de
réputation, il se peut très bien que
dans les semaines qui viennent, il y ait
peut-être 3 millions de barils par jour
de pétrole russes qui ne trouvent pas
preneur.
Et peut-être demain. Et parquoi on
remplace ça au niveau mondial ? Et ça,
on n'est pas dans 5 à 10 ans, on est
peut-être, c'est un scénario encore une
fois, il y a pas, c'est pas une
certitude. Lyon non plus n'a pas de
boule de cristal, pas plus que que
Nicolas et moi. Mais c'est un scénario
qu'il faut envisager. Et là, on est
vraiment dans le très court terme. Où
est-ce qu'on va chercher ce pétrole
supplémentaire, ce gaz supplémentaire
par rapport alors que le pétrole et le
gaz russe pour l'instant ne font pas
l'objet de sanction directe à part
l'embargo américain. Mais les Européens
n'ont pas dit "Demain, on se passe de
pétrole et de gaz russe puisqu'ils
savent que ce n'est pas possible.
Sauf les Anglais."
Sauf les anglais. Tu as raison
effectivement. Mais l'Union européenne,
pardon, j'aurais dû être plus précis.
L'Union européenne dit "Demain, pas
question de me passer du pétrolier du
gars rousse, je le fais dans 5 ans et je
commence maintenant à faire ce qu'il
faut pour le réduire mais on peut pas
s'en passer en Union européenne demain."
Et voilà. Donc il y a un vrai problème
peut-être à court terme, à moyen terme
évidemment à long terme peut-être que
nous serons tous morts comme pour
reprendre une parole célèbre, mais en
tout cas à court terme, à moyen terme,
on a un vrai problème.
Il y a quand même un scénario où aussi
la Russie et l'Europe se rabiboche.
Oui.
Parce que la Russie n'est pas le premier
pays à avoir eu des sanctions
financières euh voir des embargots. On a
le Venéuela, on a l'Iran, qu'est-ce qui
se passe en ce moment sur le pétrole ?
On est sur le point de signer, de se
rabibocher avec les Iraniens. Pourquoi
est-ce que fait Joe Biden fait ça ?
Parce que les prix du carburant aux
États-Unis sont au plus haut et qu'il a
prévu de tout faire pour les faire
baisser. Et le prochain sur la liste,
c'est le Venezuela euh où ils avaient
essayé de faire partir Nicolas Maduro
sans succès. Euh et le Venezuela a quand
même, même si c'est un pétrole d'une
qualité moindre, les plus grandes
réserves du monde. Donc la réale
politique voudra peut-être que
aujourd'hui finalement on a parlé des
des sources d'approvisionnement
alternative, donc le Qatar, les
États-Unis, peut-être un peu d'Afrique
du Nord mais ce qui est surtout mis en
avance c'est le les économies, la
sobriété, la décroissance, on appelle ça
comme on veut, mais notre système
notre système capitalisme axé sur la
croissance qui nous permet rembourser
notamment nos dettes, pas sûr qu'il soit
vraiment compatible avec une telle
destruction de la demande
puisqueaujourd'hui on dit sur les 150
milliards de mètres c de mèt cb de gaz
russe on peut on a des solutions pour en
substituer 100 milliards mais il en
reste 50 et alors dans dans les 100
milliards d'ailleurs, il me semble qu'il
a déjà inclus la destruction de la
demande si je dis pas de bêtises
le
ou la sobriété
tu vas évoquer
la récession
ou la Ouais, j'appelle sa austérité,
décroissance, sobriété pour moi c'est le
même.
Tu as évoqué Nicolas deux pays
importants, Iran et Venezuela.
Euh l'Iran, il y a donc effectivement,
on est peut-être à la veille à confirmer
d'un accord sur le programme nucléaire
de l'Iran entre les États-Unis et
l'Iran.
Accord pourrait déboucher sur la levée
d'une partie des sanctions économiques
américaines contre l'Iran, imposé depuis
2018 à l'époque par l'administration de
Donald Trump. Et en échange, l'Iran
s'engagerait à respecter complètement
l'accord qu'il avait signé en juillet
2015 sur son programme nucléaire. Donc
ça c'est un petit peu les bases de de
l'accord. Si cet accord est annoncé
demain ou vraiment à très court terme,
l'Iran pourrait en 2022, donc c'est
important pour les Européens par rapport
à la situation actuelle, en tout cas
pour l'aspect pétrolier, l'Iran pourrait
en 2022 augmenter sa production et ses
exportations pétrolières d'environ 1,3
1,5 million de barils par jour dans les
mois qui viennent. Là, on n'est pas dans
le moyen terme parce que les capacités,
elles existent simplement du fait des
sanctions américaines. Des pays
n'osaient plus acheter du pétrole
iranien de peur de tomber sous le coup
des sanctions américaines. Donc, les
débouchés de l'Iran fondaient comme
neige au soleil et donc évidemment ce
pays rébaissait sa production mais il
peut l'augmenter s'il retrouve ses
débouchés demain. L'Iran est également
une grande puissance gazière, sauf que
le paradoxe, c'est que ce pays exporte
peu de gaz parce qu'il a peu développé
de projets d'exportation. Donc le gaz
iranien, c'est une solution à moyen et à
long terme, pas à court terme. Par
contre, le pétrole iranien, si l'accord
évidemment est signé, peut être une
partie encore une fois de la solution
pour le pétrole à court terme 2022. Le
Venezuela, euh Nicolas vient de le
rappeler, c'est les plus grosses
réserves pétrolières prouvées estimées
actuellement au monde devant même
l'Arabie Saoudite.
On va reparler des réserves prouvées
juste après.
D'accord. Mais donc c'est un géant
pétrolier en terme de potentiel. Mais ce
pays
s'effondre depuis le début du siècle et
sa production pétrolière alors qu'il a
des réserves énormes et dans les
derniers mois autour de 500 600000
barils par jour. Alors que ce pays euh
produisait plus de 3 millions de barils
de pétrole par jour il y a 20 ans. Donc
un effondrement total dans lequel les
sanctions américaines ont une part de
responsabilité mais une part seulement.
Euh là par contre pour le Venezuela, si
Washington et Caracas arrivaient demain
et ma phrase commence par si à se mettre
d'accord parce que c'est pas fait, le
secteur pétrolier au Venezuela a
tellement été dégradé depuis le début du
siècle que là il faudra investir. C'est
pas comme l'Iran qui peut repartir dans
les mois qui viennent en terme de
production et d'exploitation de pétrole.
Donc le Venezuela ne serait pas
forcément une solution pour l'Europe
pour 2022 si elle devait faire le tour
du monde pour trouver plus de pétrole en
raison de la guerre en Ukraine.
Nicolas délier un peu ou je passe une
autre question. Non, juste pour terminer
dans une des solutions comme le disait
Francis, si on perd 3 millions de barils
de la Russie, vraisemblablement la seule
solution à court terme s'appelle la
destruction de la demande. C'està dire
que les prix vont augmenter et les gens
qui peuvent moins se payer le pétrole et
bien arrêteront arrêteront d'en acheter.
E j'avais un autre chose mais j'ai perdu
mon point. Donc
comme ça je peux poser ma question.
On parle de réserve prouvée. Alors déjà
qui est ce qui fait l'audit des réserves
? Comment ça se passe ?
L'Arabie Saoudite et ses copains autour.
Est-ce que permettez-moi l'expression,
est-ce qu'il joue pas un petit peu de la
flû ? Attends, j'ai j'ai retrouvé mon
point, je te le fais en 2 secondes. Euh
donc on parle de la destruction de la
demande qui va qui va être liée à à
l'augmentation du prix. Aujourd'hui, en
fait, qu'est-ce qu'on devrait faire pour
pour se passer de pétrole ? On devrait
trouver des alternatives et justement
augmenter artificiellement les prix. Il
se passe exactement l'inverse. Tous les
pays au monde sont en train de de
stimuler la demande en faisant des
réductions sur les prix de pétrole. Donc
à partir du 1er avril, en France, vous
pourrez avoir 18 centimes de réduction,
en Espagne 20 centimes. Au Royaume-Uni
combien. En Californie, les gens vont
recevoir chez eux une carte bancaire
prépayée avec 400 dollars par pouvoir
s'acheter du carburant. Donc on va
encore plus stimuler euh le le la
demande pour faire un parallèle puisque
le pétrole est un peu une drogue. C'est
comme si on allait voir un toxico qu'on
lui disait "Mais maintenant il faut que
tu baisses ta production
un toxicoman
et on lui dit "Ben tiens, on va te
donner 20 € pour pouvoir t'acheter de la
drogue." Alors, je suis pas sûr que ça a
les fait escomter.
Ouais. Donc revenons revenons à notre
question de de réserve prouvée, pas
prouvé. Comment comment se passent les
audition les audites ? Euh comment on
fait pour auditer les réserves de
pétrole en Arabie Saoudite ? Il faut
faire partie de la famille royale
en Arabie Saoudite ça c'est en Arabie
Saoudite il y a il n'y a pas d'audit
indépendant je dirais parce que il y
audit et audit euh
indépendance c'est indépendance aussi il
y a deux mots effectivement importants
audit et indépendant. Alors, l'Arabie
Saoudite euh a le mastodonde pétrolier
mondial qui s'appelle Saou Ramko. C'est
la compagnie pétrolière nationale du
royaume saoudien.
Euh cette compagnie a énormément de
compétences et d'expertise dans le
domaine du pétrole depuis des dizaines
d'années. Au départ, c'est une création
américaine. La Ramo, c'est quatre
compagnies pétrolières américaines parmi
les plus grandes du monde qui créent à
Ramko en Arabie Saoudite qui est ensuite
nationalisé, ça devient Saoud Ramko.
Maintenant on redit à Ramko mais c'est
toujours nationalisé. 98,5 % de
participation de l'État saoudien dans le
capital. Il y a juste 1,5 % qui se
promènent en bourse quelque part.
Euh donc ce sont des gens qui ont des
compétences et une expertise
indiscutable dans le domaine du pétrole.
Mais évidemment l'Arabie Saoudite n'est
pas le pays le plus transparent au
monde. Ça c'est une expression très
diplomatique he que je viens d'utiliser.
Et par conséquent, qui peut aller voir
les chiffres de l'Arabie Saoudite pour
dire "Ah là on n'est pas tout à fait
d'accord avec vous." Bon, quand on est
face à des compagnies privées, euh par
exemple côté à la bourse de New York,
euh donc là il y a la fameuse commission
des opérations de bourse, la Securities
and Exchange Commission, la SEC, hein,
qui est bon qui veille de près au grain
et donc vous devez en tant que compagnie
privée côté à New York faire auditer vos
réserves par justement des auditeurs
compétents et indépendants. Ça c'est une
obligation. Mais dans le monde, la plus
grande partie des réserves sont
contrôlées par des compagnies
pétrolières nationales
dont le seul actionnaire ou quasiment
est un gouvernement qui lui n'a pas les
obligations parce que Saudi Ramco n'est
pas côté à la bourse de New York, pas
plus que l'Abuhabi National Oil Company,
pas plus que la National Iranian Oil
Company et ainsi de suite. Donc là, on a
évidemment plus de flou. C'est c'est
intéressant de rappeler d'ailleurs parce
que beaucoup de gens pensent que les
grandes entreprises prétolières sont
responsables du du changement
climatique. Je crois que c'est 15 % de
la production de pétrole hein qui sont
dans les
alors que 85 % c'est les États.
Alors tu as parlé de l'Arabie Saoudite,
il faut savoir quand même que les
réserves ont on ont un impact puisque
dans l'OPEP le quota de production
historiquement était proportionnel à vos
réserves. Et donc après le contre-choc
pétrolier en 1985, il y a eu tout un
petit jeu où ils ont chacun augmenté
leur réserve pour pouvoir produire plus
de pétrole et donc augmenter les
rentrées. L'exemple intéressant, c'est
le Venezuela aussi. Comment est-ce qu'il
est devenu la première réserve mondiale
de pétrole devant l'Arabie Saoudite ? Il
me semble qu'à la fin des années 2010,
Hugo Chavez avait envie d'avoir les plus
grandes réserves et donc il a demandé à
à ses équipes quelles sont les réserves
de l'Arabie Saoudite euh qui devait
peut-être de 260 milliards tout à fait
et donc il les a mis peut-être à 270
juste au-dessus pour être le premier et
donc il y a eu aucun contrôle et dans
les mois qui ont suivi les gens disaient
"Ah ben c'est trop gros, c'est pas
possible et puis finalement c'est rentré
dans les mœurs et Ça a été repris dans
les chiffres de BP et donc aujourd'hui
c'est les premières réserves mondiales
parce que c'est ce qu'avait décidé Hugo
Chavez à la fin des années 2000.
Vu le caractère stratégique du pétrole,
afficher des réserves très importantes
et dire je suis numéro 1 ou numéro 2
enfin très bien placé évidemment ça
accroit en tant que pays en tant qu'état
votre importance géopolitique au niveau
mondial.
On vient vous faire la cour plus
facilement. C'est c'est clair. On va
vous inviter plus souvent pour le balin.
C'est que si vous dites "Moi, désolé,
j'ai rien, je suis à sec." C'est
On fermera aussi les yeux quand vous
passez un journaliste au Mix. Ça c'est
aussi ce que l'on appelle
malheureusement entre guillemets la
réale politique. que il est clair que un
pays comme l'Arabie Saoudite qui au
regard de euh des droits de l'homme euh
des droits de l'homme
Oui, c'est un c'est un trois mots qui
fait
parlons pas des droits de la femme.
Euh a évidemment des comets depuis des
décennies des des violations
extrêmement importantes.
droit de la femme, droit des minorités
religieuses chites en Arabie Saoudite,
droits des travailleurs migrants, les
opposants, les défenseurs des droits de
l'homme et cetera. Bon, on peut, il y a
une longue liste, hein, mais comment
est-ce que ce pays n'a jamais été de la
part des pays occidentaux ou très peu ou
très discrètement mis en accusation ?
Évidemment, la réponse est tout le monde
la connaît, c'est c'est le pétrole est
donc l'importance géopolitique du
royaume saoudien. par rapport par
rapport à cela. Mais voilà, nous sommes
face à une euh des incertitudes. Un
autre exemple bien connu, c'est l'Iran
et l'Irak. Ces pays se tiennent dans un
mouchoir de poche en terme de classement
des réserves. Et souvent dans les années
passées, on constatait que quand l'un de
ces deux pays disait "Mon chiffre de
réserve, je viens de le réévaluer c'est
de temps, l'autre pays peu de temps
après disait "Mon chiffre, je viens de
le réévaluer, il est supérieur à ce
qu'il y avait avant." Bon voilà, il y a
un certain nombre d'exemples, ce qui ne
veut pas dire que il y a pas plein de
pétrole au Moyen-Orient, soyons clair
hein, ils n'ont pas inventé tout ça. Le
Moyen-Orient, c'est la région où il y a
le plus de pétrole dans le monde. Ça
c'est absolument incontestable. C'est
une éponge à pétrole et à gaz. C'est là
aussi le plus de gaz naturel d'ailleurs
dans le monde. En terme de pays, les
plus importantes réserves, c'est la
Russie. Mais en terme de région, pour le
pétrole gaz, c'est le Moyen-Orient. Donc
c'est considérable. Ensuite, des États
peuvent être tentés pour différentes
raisons, d'avoir la main parfois un
petit peu lourde en terme de chiffre.
des chiffres qui leur donnent une
importance stratégique et géopolitique
plus grande.
Alors d'après euh nos sources parce que
on s'est amusé à projeter
nos capacités chez les pétroliers, il y
aurait une Arabie Saoudite en dessous de
l'Arabie Saoudite encore. C'est-à-dire
que
ce qui a produit l'Arabie Saoudite
depuis le départ où ils étaient
chameliers et ensuite sortis de du
gouderon par les Américains et ils ont
encore la capacité de produire
exactement la même chose.
Un pétrole de Rochem il semble.
Donc la question que je me pose à 11
millions de bariles de pétrole par jour
de consommation mondiale avec une
croissance exponentielle qui est
nécessaire pour nos partis politiques
pour maintenir un un calme de nos
populations.
Ça va tenir jusqu'à quand les réserves
de pétrole mondial ? On encore pour
combien ? 5 ans, 10 ans, 30 ans, 40 ans
comme on nous annonce tous les 40 ans à
votre avis ?
Alors, si on regarde d'abord les
découvertes,
je crois qu'en 2021, on a découvert 5
milliards de barils et on en consommait
7 fois plus, 35 milliards. Donc, on est
à un baril découvert, 7 barils
consommés. Donc, ça va baisser de 6
euh à chaque année. Maintenant, quand on
regarde les réserves, combien d'années
de réserves nous restent-il ? Donc, on a
parlé tout à l'heure des réserves qui
sont des réserves financières
ou politiques. Donc c'est des réserves
qui augmentent au fur et à mesure du
temps, au fur et à mesure des
réévaluations
par les par les différents dirigeants
des compagnies pétrolières nationales et
aussi parce que quand un puit de pétrole
est découvert en fait on ne déclare que
10 % de de sa de sa réserve pour des
raisons financières et qu'au fur et à
mesure de son exploitation on va
rajouter la suite et donc ça donne un
effet que ça augmente en permanence.
Maintenant, quand on regarde les
réserves techniques qui sont des
réserves, des données qui ont les les
entreprises pétrolière mais qui sont pas
disponibles pour tout le monde et qu'on
on on emploie une technique, ça va être
un peu technique, qui s'appelle le
bagtil, c'est-à-dire que quand on prend
un puit de pétrole, on va allouer toute
sa réserve au jour de sa découverte et
pas comme je vous l'ai dit, 10 % le jour
de la découverte, 10 % 5 ans après, 10 %
5 ans après. On se rend compte qu'en
fait et bien il y a 30 ans il nous
restait 60 ans de consommation de
pétrole et qu'aujourd'hui 30 ans plus
tard il nous en reste 30 ans. Donc on
est bien on est bien sur cette baisse
là. Le pétrole va pas disparaître du
jour au lendemain. Vous avez des gens
qui pensent que
il va pas disparaître du tout.
Non, il va pas disparaître mais il va
disparaître peut-être de certains usages
où les gens ne pourront plus le payer.
Par exemple, dans la voiture, certaines
personnes pensent que la voiture
électrique par exemple va nous permettre
de régler ce problème, le fameux pic de
la demande. Moi, je regarde de près les
voitures électriques et donc je regarde
de près le paradis des voitures
électriques. Quel est le paradis des
voitures électriques ? la Norvège.
La Norvège qui est aussi d'ailleurs plus
grand producteur de pétrole exportateur
euh en Europe. Euh et donc en Norvège
aujourd'hui presque 100 % des voitures
vendues neuves sont électriques.
Et donc quand on regarde Et quand on
regarde et ça nous en Europe, bah en
France, on s'est mis comme objectif d'y
arriver euh dans 20 ans 2040.
Et donc ce qui fait qu'en Norvège, vous
avez à peu près 10 à 15 % des voitures
en circulation, peut-être 15 %
aujourd'hui qui sont des voitures
électriques. Mais quel est l'impact sur
la consommation de pétrole en Norvège ?
10 %.
Donc on peut espérer en 2040 peut-être
une baisse de consommation de 10 %.
Allez, on va dire 2030 parce que ils ont
découvert qu'il fallait se débarrasser
du pétrole. Donc on peut espérer 10 % de
baisse de consommation dans 10 ans, mais
il en reste 90. Euh donc malheureusement
ça va se faire un petit peu dans la
douleur. Alors il y a un exemple de pays
que j'aime bien citer qui a déjà fait
cet exercice de baisser sa consommation
de pétrole d'un tiers en se privant du
pétrole russe.
Ça s'appelle Cuba et ça s'est passé au
début des années 90. Ça s'est passé dans
la douleur. Bien évidemment du jour au
lendemain. L'approvisionnement de
pétrole à Cuba a baissé d'un/3.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait ? Donc on peut
voir, il y a un très bon documentaire
comment Cuba a survécu au pétrole que je
vous recommande qui fait 50 minutes. Et
donc on voit toutes les les solutions
qu'ils ont mis en place sur le
transport. Ils ont découvert le vélo,
ils avaient toutes les grosses voitures
américaines. Ils ont importé des vélos
et ils se sont mis au vélo. Euh ils se
sont mis à faire des ils ont converti
des semi-remorques en bus. Donc la
remorque ils ont fait pour que les gens
puissent prennent le bus. Il me semble
qu'ils ont rendu l'autostop obligatoire.
Donc vous vous passez en voiture,
quelqu'un fait l'autostop interdit de
refuser et je crois que c'est amende ou
un peu plus que ça hein. Et puis il y a
pas que ça, il y avait aussi un énorme
problème avec Cuba, c'est que ils
avaient l'agriculture la plus mécanisée
des Amériques, plus que l'Amérique du
Nord. des énormes parcelles qu'ils
allaient exploiter avec des tracteurs
russes. Sauf que les pièces de rechange
russes, des tracteurs, ils les ont plus
eu. Donc qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait ? Ils
ont redécoupé toutes les parcelles, ils
sont mis à lancer la permaculture et ils
ont développé des potagers urbains
beaucoup à la Havane. Aujourd'hui à la
Havane, plus de la moitié, je crois que
c'est presque 70 % de
l'approvisionnement fruits et légumes
pousse à la vanne et dans les environs.
Donc on connaît les solutions, on
connaît ce qui peut se passer. Je pense
que ça va être un tout petit peu plus
compliqué à Paris d'aller faire pousser
70 % de nos fruits du légume dans les
environs en Île-de-France. Mais par
contre, on pourra faire du vélo.
On pourra faire du vélo, on pourra faire
du covoiturage. Euh et il va surtout
falloir s'organiser assez rapidement
parce que je vous rappelle que il y a
quelques années, en 2018, on a eu quand
même la crise des gilets jaunes qui a
été dont l'amorceur était quand même une
augmentation du prix du pétrole. Euh et
quand on parle de transport et de
mobilité, vous avez les cabinets de
conseil Mcinse qui vont vous parler de
smart city et cetera pour se déplacer en
vélo, en hélicoptère, en drone et
cetera. Non, mais il y a pas
d'hélicoptère.
Ce qui est vrai, ce qui est important,
c'est la mobilité quand les gens ont pas
d'alternative, hein. Donc c'est à la
campagne parce que il y a pas de
transport en commun, il y a pas de piste
cyclable parce que la route nationale,
vous allez pas la partager avec le 44
tonn. Donc il y a que la voiture comme
solution. Donc si pour une raison ou
soit le prix du pétrole est trop cher,
soit il y a moins de pétrole où il y a
une pénurie de diesel, mais vous avez
plus de travail. C'est finito. Et donc
là, on s'est pas trop on s'est pas trop
organisé pour se régler ce problème
alors que ça a quand même été la crise
sociale la plus grave des 20 dernières
années et qu'on a mis à peu près un an
et demi à leur lâcher 15 milliards.
Bon ben, c'était le début de l'argent
magique. Aujourd'hui, ça va plus vite.
Ça part plus vite l'argent mais
aujourd'hui à part leur donner de
l'argent et alimenter cette dépendance,
cette drogue, on va avoir un problème.
On ne sort pas évidemment facilement et
rapidement d'un modèle économique
euh fondé sur une production et une
consommation très importante d'énergie
fossiles dont au premier chef le
pétrole, première énergie consommée dans
le monde.
Et comme le disait Nicolas, c'est
compliqué,
ça prendra du temps, ça va coûter
beaucoup d'argent et ce sera pas simple
économiquement et socialement parce
qu'effectivement l'exemple de Cuba est
tout à fait intéressant mais je pense
qu'il y aura peu de candidats à
l'élection présidentielle ou législative
qui feront campagne pour dire au à
l'opinion publique française, écoutez
voilà le modèle pour l'avenir, pour se
passer du pétrole. Regardez ce que font
les Cubains. On va suivre cet
exemple-là. Il y a peu de chance que ça
marche électoralement. Donc voilà. Euh
c'est c'est extrêmement complexe.
Comment est-ce qu'on sort de ça ? Avec
quel calendrier ? Avec quelle
articulation ?
Je suis plus optimiste que Nicolas pour
la question des réserves pétrolières,
mais tout en sachant que on est
évidemment sur des données
avec une marche d'incertitude importante
pour certaines des raisons que nous
avons évoqué, y compris politique et
financière et et autres. Je serai plus
optimiste sur le potentiel, mais ensuite
les réserves, c'est il faut encore les
mobiliser. Supposons que il y ait encore
plein de pétrole dans le sous-sol,
supposons.
Mais si on n'investit pas suffisamment
pour aller chercher ce pétrole et
transformer ses réserves en capacité de
production et en production, on peut
avoir un problème demain. Le problème
n'étant pas les réserves mais étant
qu'on a pas suffisamment investi pour.
Or, les compagnies pétrolières ont pas
mal réduit leurs investissements
notamment après une forte chute des prix
du pétrole entre 2014 et 2016. Et après,
on a l'année 2020 où les prix du pétrole
Covid récession mondiale chutent encore
très fortement et à nouveau les
compagnies pétrolières notamment privé
réduisent fortement leurs
investissements. Donc on a dans une
période de temps assez courte, c'est pas
50 ans de différence, 2014-2 2016,
deux fortes réductions des
investissements par les compagnies
pétrolières. Ce qui fait que évidemment
dans les années qui viennent, on
pourrait avoir un problème de pénurie
pétrolière qui ne serait pas causé à
cette échéance là par un problème
d'insuffisance des réserves, mais par un
problème d'insuffisance de capacité de
production, problème lui-même lié à une
insuffisance d'investissement par les
acteurs pétroliers mondiaux. Et comme le
monde repose encore aujourd'hui
largement sur le pétrole, c'est un
scénario qui est très inquiétant et
c'est un scénario qui pourrait être
encore une fois conditionnel de moyen
terme et pas forcément de long terme.
Oui, pour rendre ça imager, vous avez un
réservoir, vous avez un robinet.
Le problème est plus le robinet qui
aujourd'hui est ouvert au maximum et
qu'à priori on aura du mal à à augmenter
et qui va plutôt se réduire. C'est
plutôt un problème de robinet, de flux.
de débit qu'un problème qu'un problème
de réserve.
On est en période électorale. Je ne vais
pas vous demander pour qui vous allez
voter.
Par contre, je vais vous poser la
question concernant les questions
énergétiques.
Si vous avez étudié un petit peu le
spectre
selon vous, qui
collerait à une réalité plus proche de
la réalité dans son programme ?
Il y a eu The Shift Project.
Voilà. qui a essayé de de faire une
grille de lecture de la capacité des
partis politiques français à appliquer
une politique
avant-gardiste concernant la question de
transition énergétique.
Ça donne une bonne base. Pour vous, quel
parti politique tient la route sur les
questions énergétiques ? Alors ça peut
être des questions énergétiques de
diplomatie, des questions. Je vous
écoute Francis ou Nicolas ? Moi, je vais
m'en remettre aux travaux des 12 ou
15000 bénévoles du Shift Project qui
avaient travaillé récemment et vous
aviez invité Jean-Marc Jcovici sur le
plan de transformation de l'économie
française, le plan de résilience que
voulait Emmanuel Macron. Alors eux, ils
ont pris 2 ans et 12000 personnes pour
le faire. C'est un plan sur 30 ans.
Emmanuel Macron, son plan de résilience
c'est je te donne 18 centimes le 1er
avril, c'est pas une blague. Euh donc
euh
et qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait ? Ils ont
fait ce rapport, ils ont épluché à la
loupe tous les programmes des candidats.
Personnellement, je me suis assez peu
intéressé et effectivement euh je crois
que le verdict, c'est que les deux plus
sérieux, c'est Yannick Jade et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon. C'est ce que j'ai entendu ce
matin à la radio. Euh j'en saurais pas
beaucoup plus sur ce sujet-là. Euh ce
que je peux dire, c'est que les écolos
euh en tout cas moi je trouve que nous
ont fait perdre beaucoup de temps depuis
20 ans. Euh ils ont voulu s'inspirer de
ce qui se passait bien en Allemagne avec
les écolos qui avaient été élus en 98
avec la coalition avec Gear Schreuder
qui avait réussi à imposer la sortie du
nucléaire 20 ans plus tard. Donc qui
sont devenus un modèle euh pour nos
écolos qui y sont arrivés en 2012 avec
l'alliance avec François Hollande, c'est
50 % d'électricité nucléaire et cetera
et qui fait que depuis 20 ans, on ne
parle que d'électricité.
H
le débat national de la transition
énergétique était juste là pour valider
la proposition lancée à une émission sur
TF1 du candidat François Hollande. Le
mot pétrole apparaît trois fois.
Euh, on a un parc nucléaire qui a 35 ans
d'âge. On n pas investi un COPEC dedans.
On a une falaise qui arrive sur ce sur
ce parc nucléaire.
Une falaise de quel type ?
Une falaise de type CAPEX
d'investissement parce que on a
construit en 10 ans 10 15 ans 60
réacteurs nucléaires et après on a plus
investi 1 €. On est juste des rentiers
de cette électricité nucléaire mais il
va falloir les remplacer. Ils ont tous
35 ans d'âge. On voit certains
dysfonctionnements, quelques fissures et
cetera. EDF qui avait anticipé de pré de
produire 400 TW en 2022 annoncé que ce
serait pas 400 mais 300. Sachant que la
France produit une grande partie de
l'électricité de base en Europe, pas que
en France. Et donc ces terraurs sont
très importants. Donc ça fait 20 ans
qu'en fait l'énergie n'est pas au cœur
du débat et que on oublie que
l'électricité c'est 40 % de l'énergie.
et qu'en fait le reste c'est du pétrole
et du gaz et que c'est du pétrole pour
nous déplacer et qu'on va pas le
remplacer du jour au lendemain par
l'électricité et que c'est du gaz pour
nous chauffer, c'est du gaz pour nos
industries et on en a pas parlé pendant
20 ans et là on se réveille en 2022, on
découvre ah quand même peut-être qu'il
est temps de parler de pétrole et de
gaz. Donc moi, je suis un peu remonté
sur euh sur ces 20 ans de perdu euh par
les écolopes, par Emmanuel Macron aussi
qui n'était pas obligé de fermer la
centrale de Fessenheim et de et de
rouvrir ou de faire tourner les
centrales à charbon. Euh c'est quand
même c'est quand même euh incroyable que
finalement ce soit Barbara Pompili qui
rouvre les centrales à charrabant. C'est
surprenant.
Je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
l'analyse que tu viens de développer.
C'est vrai que quand on suit dans la
durée euh la politique énergétique
française, les débats autour de
l'énergie, on est frappé par le fait que
depuis pas mal d'années, parler
d'énergie, ça veut dire parler
renouvelable électricité, ce qui est
bien évidemment, c'est une partie du
débat mais c'est pas tout le débat. Dans
un monde dominé par trois énergies
fossiles, pétrole, charbon, gaz naturel,
par ordre décroissant. Et même si on est
on correspond pas tout à fait à la
moyenne mondiale, notamment la France,
puisque la première énergie dans notre
pays, c'est l'électricité provenant du
nucléaire. Mais l'Union européenne
n'échappe pas non plus à ce poids des
énergies fossiles dont on parle très
peu. On a décidé de zapper complètement
en disant ces énergies fossiles c'est
pas bon. changement climatique. Donc on
fait comme si elles n'existent pas mais
elles sont là et elles sont dans le
paysage. Et tout d'un coup effectivement
en 2022 guerre en Ukraine à alors tout
le monde se met à se parler ce qui est
bien du pétrole et du gaz alors que on
aurait pu et dû le faire auparavant. Je
suis effectivement assez euh
sceptique, pour le dire gentiment, euh
sur l'état de nos débats euh énergétique
euh en France depuis des années sur euh
grande partie du du spectre du spectre
politique euh parce que je trouve que
ces débats sont souvent très pauvres,
extrêmement partiels,
extrêmement partiaux, ça peut aller en
même temps. Et et puis un autre élément,
c'est que
nous parlions du chift projet qui a fait
une étude extrêmement intéressante par
rapport au programme des candidats sous
l'angle de la transition énergétique de
la lutte contre le changement
climatique. Problème majeur. Donc c'est
leur angle d'attaque si je puis dire.
Euh une politique énergétique
depuis, j'allais dire depuis toujours,
pas depuis toujours, mais depuis
longtemps, euh ça renvoie à trois
dimensions.
La sécurité des approvisionnements
énergétiques. En ce moment, c'est un
sujet d'actualité, mais c'est c'est pas
seulement un sujet d'actualité, c'est un
sujet majeur pour n'importe quel pays
dans le monde. On ne peut pas se passer
l'énergie.
la compétitivité économique.
Si on pelle énergie très cher, quel
impact sur notre système industriel, nos
entreprises ? On en a parlé tout à
l'heure et évidemment la protection de
l'environnement dont la question majeure
de la lutte contre le changement
climatique. Mais une politique
énergétique, ce n'est pas seulement la
protection de l'environnement.
On doit l'étudier pour tous les pays du
monde, pas seulement la France, pas
seulement l'Union européenne, au regard
de ces trois critères.
Si on en zappe deux au profit du 3è qui
est majeur, qui monte en puissance et
c'est très bien, c'est très important
mais le fait de le faire monter en
puissance ne fait pas disparaître les
deux premiers sécurité des
approvisionnements, compétitivité
économique.
Donc ça c'est c'est des éléments
vraiment de base qui sont élémentaires
et qui dans le débat public sur ces
questions-là sont complètement tout ça
passe à la poubelle. Et résultat, on se
prend le boomerang en pleine figure le
24 février 2022 en disant "Ah oui, le
pétrole et le gaz, ça existe encore. Ah
oui, on va avoir des problème. Donc il
faut quand même qu'on s'en occupe
et qu'on s'en occupe dans une
perspective très court terme, très
électoraliste et cetera. Qu'est-ce qu'on
fait sur les prix du carburant ? Mo- 18
centimes, moins 15 centimes et cera mais
c'est pas du tout à la hauteur des
enjeux. Alors, je vais vous poser une
question très personnelle à tous les
deux avant de redonner la parole à
Nicolas.
On parle bien de cellules de prospective
étatique de d'anticipation de de de du
se projeter dans l'avenir.
Gouverner c'est prévoir.
Exactement. Exactement. La question que
je vous pose qui est très personnelle.
Est-ce que les services de renseignement
français sont allés voir nos deux amis
que nous avons aujourd'hui pour leur
dire "Bon, écoutez les gars, euh
faudrait un petit peu nous tuyoter parce
que on est soit borne, soit aveugle,
soit malvoyant, malentendant et on a
besoin un petit peu de vos lumières.
Est-ce que un jour vous avez été
approché par les services de
renseignement pour les aider
à être un petit peu plus prévoyant ou
peut-être vous connaissez déjà des
analystes dans leur cellule de
prospective ou vous savez déjà qu'ils
ont qui n'ont aucune cellule de
prospective sur le sujet ?
Moi ce que je peux vous dire si j'ai été
approché par des ondes du renseignement
je c'est probablement pas qu'ils en
faisaient partie mais a priori je ne
pense pas. Ce que je peux vous dire,
c'est que nous avec l'association pour
l'étude du pic pétrolier, on a eu des
échanges notamment avec le qu d'ors
ministère des affaires étrangères. On a
essayé de provoquer une discussion mais
ils ont toujours tourné en dérive ce
sujet. Tourné en dérive le sujet du pic
pétrolier, des approvisionnements des
contraintes. Donc c'est quelque chose
qui ne les intéressait pas, qui n'existe
pas. le pétrole c'est illimité, il y a
pas de problème.
Personnellement, j'ai travaillé donc
pendant 4 ans au sein de France
stratégique qui est une cellule
prospective qui dépend des services du
premier ministre qui est ce qui reste du
commissariat au plan hein qui a été créé
en 46 par le général de Gaulle et qui a
piloté l'économie pour la reconstruction
les tran glorieuses et qui s'est arrêté
plus ou moins de sa belle mort à la fin
des années des années
90 et donc aujourd'hui on publie des
études prospectives. Moi, j'ai publié
notamment une étude sur les émissions de
CO2 des voitures pour réduire la
consommation de pétrole russe des
voitures en proposant par exemple de
donner de l'argent à des gens qui
peuvent acheter une voiture qui consomme
moins. Donc un bonus malus sur le poids.
Le gouvernement n'en a pas voulu. Ça a
été tourné en dérision par Ellisabeth
Born. Euh je voulais publier, on a
publié il y a un an une très belle une
étude très intéressante sur les
contraintes d'approvisionnement
d'électricité que vous allez pouvoir
retrouver sur le site de France
Stratégie que je vous recommande mais on
n' pas réussi à publier sur le pétrole
et le gaz et mon interprétation c'est
que tant que le prix du pétrole n'avait
pas dépassé les 100 dollars, c'était
sous le radar.
Donc j'ai quitté en décembre et il est
passé à 100 dollars en février
dépité
ou à moins que le fait que Nicolas et
quitté France stratégie et fait passer
la barre des 100 dollars par baril au
prix du pétrole. C'est aussi scénario
possible. Mais
toi aussi tu avais des put option
euh par rapport à la question posée, je
mon impression personnelle
euh c'est que
service
tout à fait. Non, je je pensais bien à
cette question là. Dans l'appareil
d'État français,
les militaires
et les services de renseignement
sont parmi ceux qui continuent à
s'intéresser au pétrôle et au gaz parce
qu'ils savent que c'est stratégique.
appareilémentaire mais comme l'a rappelé
Nicolas une grande partie de l'appareil
d'État
à part ce dont je viens de parler pense
que le pétrole et le gaz n'existe plus
jusqu'à au 24 février 2022 mais les
militaires et les services de
renseignement qui par définition
travaillent 37 jours par an sur des
questions stratégiques n'ignorent pas le
poids des hydrocarbures dans l'économie
dans la géopolitique mondiale et donc
ils continuent à s'y intéresser. Ils
n'ont jamais cessé de s'y intéresser. Et
d'ailleurs, le Shift Project euh a
réalisé l'an dernier une étude euh pour
le compte du ministère des armées sur
les contrainte d'approvisionnement en
pétrole en Europe que vous allez pouvoir
retrouver sur leur site avec notamment
comme moteur Olivier Reche et Marc
Plaise qui sont des personnes très
compétentes qui sont allé étudier la
base de données la plus fournie qu'il
existe au niveau mondial de Restat
Energie pour voir qu'effectivement à
Horizon 2030 l'approvisionnement en
pétrole de l'Europe allait commencer à
décliner
par rapport à ces différents
fournisseurs de pétrole et que
malheureusement les articles
alternatives étaient limitées.
L'alternative sur lequel tout le monde
comptait pour le pétrole et notamment
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie,
c'était les États-Unis. C'était que le
miracle du pétrole de chisse,
aujourd'hui, on est à 10 millions de
barils par jour, qu'on puisse
l'augmenter à je crois 25 millions. Euh
mais le principal de la croissance de de
pétrole de la nouvelle offre allait
venir des États-Unis. Il faut quand même
avoir en tête que entre 2005
et aujourd'hui,
l'accroissement de l'offre de pétrole au
niveau mondial est venu de deux pays.
L'Irak
suite suite à la guerre où on a
malheureusement pas trouvé les armes de
destruction massive et les États-Unis.
Tous les autres pays producteurs de
pétrole, les baissent ont compensé les
hausses. Les deux pays qui voilà qui
font la croissance, c'est ces deux
pays-là. Donc qu'est-ce qui se passe en
Irak ? Est-ce qu'on va pouvoir augmenter
encore significativement la production
en Irak ? C'est pas forcément évident.
et les États-Unis, on est sur des
pétroes de Rochem et même aujourd'hui,
c'est une industrie qui a perdu de
l'argent pendant presque 10 ans, mais
qui aujourd'hui réalise ses meilleurs
profits puisqu'ils ont décidé de garder
un peu plus d'argent et de moins
investir, sachant qu'on est en plus dans
une période de prix élevé.
Ce que vient de dire Nicolas Rome nous
permet de souligner à nouveau ce que
nous avions évoqué en réponse à une de
vos questions précédentes, le rôle
extrêmement important dans la galaxie
mondiale du pétrole et donc dans la
géopolitique mondiale du pétrole de
l'Iran et du Venezuela. Parce que ces
deux pays pour des raisons différentes
mais principalement de nature politique
sanction économique pour ce qui concerne
l'Iran et et américaine et pour ce qui
concerne le Venezuela un peu les
sanctions américaines et beaucoup de
très mauvaises décisions prises dans la
gestion du secteur pétrolier. Mais ces
deux pays ont le potentiel de produire
et d'exporter à terme beaucoup plus de
pétrole. pétrole conventionnel du côté
de l'Iran, pétrole non conventionnel
mais différent du pétrole de Schist du
côté du Venezuela. Donc ces deux pays-là
vont évidemment être très courtisés.
Nous évoquions tout à l'heure les
négociations à Vienne en Autriche hein
sur le autour du programme nucléaire de
l'Iran. Il y a là des enjeux importants
et certains observateurs n'hésitent pas
à analyser la situation. Le retour des
parias.
L'Iran et le Venezuel étaient deux pari
pour des raisons politiques dans le
contexte actuel aggravé par la guerre en
Ukraine avec les incertitudes sur
l'approvisionnement mondial et en
particulier européen en pétrole et en
gaz et en l'occurrence surtout en
pétrole pour ces deux les deux pays que
je viens de citer. On se dit "Ah oui, ce
serait bien quand même que ces deux pays
puissent puisqu'ils ont le potentiel, il
y a pas de doute là-dessus, produire
rapidement pour l'Iran, moins rapidement
pour le Venezuela et exporter plus de
pétrole.
à croire que le monde a toujours besoin
de d'un petit paria pour maintenir son
économie. Question internet. Alors, vous
êtes pas obligé d'y répondre parce que
c'est une question qui a des
répercussions économiques un peu
profondes, mais je pense que on peut
quand même essayer de vous la poser.
Allons-nous vers une crise des subprimes
à la française à cause de l'inflation
énergétique Union européenne comprise
comme cela s'est produit en 2008 au aux
États-Unis. Risque-t-on de voir des gens
ne plus pouvoir payer leurs crédits à
cause d'un budget énergie trop élevé ?
Alors, ce qui s'était passé aux
États-Unis, la crise des subprime, c'est
que on avait toute une catégorie de
personnes, les donc les subprime, les
gens qui peuvent pas emprunter qui qui
s'étaient endetté au début des années
2000 sur des sur des prêts à taux
variables. Et donc à partir de 2004
2005, il me semble que la Fed commence à
remonter ses taux directeurs. la banque
centrale américaine remonte ses taux
directeurs et donc comme ces prêts à
taux variables sont enfin sont pas
indexés sur le taux de la de la Fed mais
les banques en conséquence de ça vont
augmenter leur propre taux à eux et donc
effectivement quand vous remboursez 1000
dollars par mois et que vous devez en
rembourser 2000 dollars ça pose un
problème. Donc aujourd'hui j'ai pas la
vision sur quelle est la proportion de
personnes aux États-Unis qui a emprunté
en taux variable. J'ai pas la boule de
cristal non plus pour voir quelle
pourrait être l'augmentation des taux de
la Fed, mais a priori euh ils ont quand
même peu de marge de manœuvre avec le
stock de dette mondial qu'on a
actuellement pour augmenter leur taux.
Le problème le plus grave dont on n pas
encore parlé aujourd'hui,
c'est pas euh forcément une crise
financière, c'est que on a parlé de
pétrole, on a parlé de gaz, on a parlé
d'engrais qui est important puisqu'il
rentre dans la production de la
nourriture pour nous mais aussi pour les
animaux. Et on a pas parlé de blé. Mais
qu'est-ce qui s'était passé au début des
années 2010 ? les fameux printemps
arabes. Les fameux printemps arabes,
c'était pas juste la démocratie pour
tous, c'était surtout une sécheresse
très importante dans le pouretour
méditerranéen et du pétrole à 147,90
aussi. Et puis c'était une sécheresse
qui avait lieu en Russie en 2010 qui
avait complètement amputé sa production
de blé. Euh et donc quand vous avez des
pays comme l'Égypte avec plus de 80
millions de personnes, peut-être un peu
plus euh qui importent 90 % de ces
céréales, et bien là vous avez euh vous
avez un petit souci. Euh et c'était ça
qui a aussi créé, si vous voulez le le
conflit en Syrie puisque les tous les
agriculteurs hein qui vivaient euh de
l'exploitation avec la sécheresse était
venue dans les villes et c'était
agglutiné et c'est ça qui petit à petit
avait débouché sur ce problème. Donc là
on a un problème sur le blé. 30 % de la
production mondrale,
20 % la Russie, 10 % l'Ukraine avec des
prix qui des prix qui explosent he des
prix du blé qui explosent. Et donc le
vrai enjeu c'est celui-là. Alors, il
nous reste a priori pour l'instant du
riz et les prix du riz ont pas explosé
et c'est ça qui fait qu'on peut
éventuellement s'en sortir. Euh mais
c'est ça qu'il va falloir regarder de
près euh dans les prochains mois. Et
quoi qu'il arrive, on va avoir de toute
façon une inflation importante puisque
le pétrole rentre dans la fabrication de
beaucoup de produits, il rentre dans le
transport de ces produits-là et bien
évidemment dès qu'on parle de
nourriture, on a besoin d'engrais et
qu'il y ait engrais gaz naturel.
Depuis 2021, nous avons une hausse
générale
des prix des matières premières,
produits agricoles,
ressources minières et matières
premières énergétiques.
Évidemment, c'est encore aggravé avec la
guerre en Ukraine depuis le mois de de
février. La Russie étant un important
exportateur comme l'a rappelé Nicolas et
l'Ukraine aussi pour l'agriculture de
produits agricoles notamment céréales.
La Russie étant un important exportateur
de ressources minières et
d'hydrocarbure, pétrole, gaz naturel et
charbon.
Les prix de l'énergie sont des prix
extrêmement sensibles
économiquement, socialement,
politiquement.
Nicolas évoqué à juste titre les
problèmes que la situation actuelle
pourrait causer pour des pays en
développement notamment africain
fortement importateur de produits
agricoles venant de la Russie de
l'Ukraine qui pour une part.
On imagine ce que peut être la récolte
ukrainienne en 2022 dans un pays en
guerre. un petit coup de plomb
et du côté de la Russie euh avec les
primes d'assurance qui explosent en mer
noire quand on trouve un assureur donc
alors il faut expliquer le le principe
des primes assurances
on est dans une zone de guerre
donc par conséquent n'importe quel
assureur normalement constitué va dire
moi pour assurer une cargaison qui va
traverser la mer noire ben évidemment si
je continue à le faire déjà certains
vont se retirer euh ça va pas vous
coûter tant je qui vais multiplier la
prime par 2 ou et cetera. Donc ça va
évidemment compliquer le transport des
céréales à travers la mer noire.
Je pour ce qui concerne la France, je
lisais dans la presse hier ou
aujourd'hui le cas d'un agriculteur qui
faisait ses compte. Il a besoin de
consommer du pétrole et notamment à
travers les carburants bien sûr
et en l'occurrence du gazol non routier
pour des machines agricoles.
Du rouge.
Oui, tout à fait. Il a besoin de
consommer du gaz naturel. Il a besoin de
consommer de l'électricité. Il faisait
ses comptes, il disait en 2022 pour son
exploitation agricole, pas pour lui, pas
pour son habitation, pour les besoins de
son travail.
Lui, il travaille pour 350 € par mois,
donc il souple à chaque fois.
Voilà, il disait "Ma facture énergétique
pour mon exploitation en 2022 va
augmenter de plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'euros." Comment est-ce que je
fais ? Comment est-ce que j'affronte
l'année 2022 ? et comme il peut pas
répercuter les prix, il s'aime pas.
C'est euh
on est face à un problème majeur,
évidemment encore plus grave dans des
pays en développement puisque là on
parle de d'aggravation potentielle de la
malnutrition pour des millions de
personnes. Mais même dans des pays
développés, industrialisés,
cette flambée des prix de l'énergie,
pétrole et donc carburant, gaz,
électricité pose des problèmes
politiques, économiques, sociaux
redoutables. Nicolas rappelait le
mouvement des gilets jaunes en France
2018. qui a commencé, rappelons-le, au
départ, après il est parti dans tous les
sens, mais au départ suite à une hausse
des taxes sur les carburant essence
gazol
à 6 centimes par litre.
Dans les dernières semaines, les
carburants en France c'est pas plus à
300 à 6 centimes par litre.
Donc on est face à des problèmes
absolument majeurs économiquement,
socialement, politiquement.
Euh une question internet euh
sur le téléphone. Est-ce qu'on peut me
l'envoyer ? Bon alors je le temps. Ah
magnifique. Merci bien. Question
internet. NG qui achète du gaz de chiste
américain pour
bouder boycotter le gaz russe. Est-ce
que c'est est-ce qu'on a vraiment
compris le problème écologique ? C'est
que on préfère
sauver de l'Ukrainien en tapant sur la
l'économie russe, sur le capital
écologique. Est-ce que est-ce que je
m'exprime correctement ? Oui. Non.
Est-ce que c'est un dilemme qu'on
s'autorise pour les 6 prochains mois ?
C'est-à-dire continuer à taper dans le
patrimoine écologique pour sauver des
vies ou pour calmer une guerre ?
Alors de deux éléments de réponse. Le
premier c'est NG effectivement c'est
l'entreprise française
qui qui importe le qui a le contrat avec
Chenère aux États-Unis donc qui importe
du gaz de chiste en GNL. Mais c'est
aussi une entreprise qui fait partie du
consortium Nordstream 2 euh qui part de
Russie, qui va dans l'Air Baltique. Donc
ce qui est ce qui était drôle entre
guillemets, c'est qu'au début du
conflit, vous avez euh Joe Biden qui a
annoncé des sanctions financières contre
les entreprises euh du consortium de
Nordstream 2 qui inclut donc NG, sachant
qu' NG, c'est l'entreprise qui importe
du gaz de chift des États-Unis.
Euh bien préparé cette histoire, j'ai
l'impression
comme toujours. Euh après,
je crois que sur l'environnement, il
faut arrêter de se se raconter des
histoires.
Si on regarde les émissions de SO2 de la
France depuis 20 ans 95,
les émissions de CO2 de la France ont
ont diminué. celle qu'on a émis au
niveau national,
mais celle qu'on a importé d'ailleurs,
elles ont explosé. Aujourd'hui, plus de
la moitié de notre empreinte carbone,
plus de la moitié, ce sont nos
importations. Et donc nous, depuis 20
ans, on ne parle que de ce qu'on produit
localement. euh et ce qu'on produit
localement, ben c'est moins la moitié du
problème. Et quand on regarde ce qu'on
produit localement, quand on regarde
quand on regarde les différents
secteurs, on va avoir le transport qui a
augmenté de 30 %.
On va avoir
le bâtiment qui est à peu près stable,
on va avoir l'énergie qui a un petit peu
baissé parce qu'on consomme un peu moins
de charbon et de fiou. Mais la plus
grosse baisse, d'où vient-elle ?
de l'industrie moin 40 %. La plus grosse
baisse des émissions de CO2 de la France
depuis 95, c'est le secteur industriel.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Ça indique notre désindustrialisation.
Désindustrial. Alors, il y a pas que de
la désindustrialisation,
il y a aussi de l'optimisation des
processus énergétiques, des choses plus
efficaces. Mais il y a beaucoup d'usines
qui étaient en France et qui sont partis
ailleurs et on est beau sur la photo, on
baisse nos émissions de CO2. C'est ça la
politique climatique de la France depuis
20 ans. Point barre. Et aussi remplacer
une source d'électricité décarbonée par
une autre source d'électricité
décarbonée. Point barre. Donc donc le
quand on on va remplacer du gaz russe
par du gaz de chiste, il faut pas trop
s'étonner non plus. Euh et moi, comme
c'est un sujet que je regarde depuis
assez longtemps parce qu'on a été euh
les auditeurs le savent peut-être pas,
mais on a été champion du monde euh des
euh des importations de gaz de chiste
américain. Ça nous arrivé euh je crois
en avril 2018. Chaque fois, je le je le
poste. Euh il y a quelques voilà, on
était le pays qui importait le plus du
gaz de chiste américain, sachant que
bien évidemment on l'interdit chez nous,
mais on fait ça sur beaucoup de choses,
on fait ça sur beaucoup d'engrais. On
interdit les engrais,
les pesticides aussi. pesticides. Voilà.
Et puis on les achète en Espagne à la
place. Je veux dire, on a un pays
malheureusement assez mal dirigé.
Non, on a un pays magnifique avec
énormément. On n pas de pétrole, on pas
on n pas le soleil et le et la plage
comme à Cuba mais on a quand même une
géographie. On a quand même vous êtes
jamais allé en Corse hein. Et vous êtes
jamais allé,
on est plutôt Non non, on é plutôt
Il faut aller à Vann. Van, c'est
magnifique.
Je connais très bien Van,
Francis.
On vient de parler de Nordstream 2.
Alors, c'est un très gros projet,
investissement 10 milliards d'euros, pas
mal. Capacité de transport de gaz russe,
55 milliards de mètres cub de gaz par
an. Pour donner une idée, la
consommation française de gaz naturel
sur un an, c'est à peu près 40 milliards
de m³. Un gros projet. Euh ce projet est
soutenu depuis des années par la Russie,
évidemment.
Gazprom et les dirigeants allemands
et arrive la guerre russo-craine ou
juste avant quelques jours auparavant on
s'en souvient le président Vladimir
Poutine reconnaît l'indépendance des
deux Républiques du Donbas Donetsk
Luansk
le chancelier allemand Olaf Scholz la
guerre n'a pas encore commencé dit dans
ces conditions-là compte tenu de ce que
vient de décider la Russie
Je ne peux pas approuver la mise en
service de Nordstream 2 en 2022 comme ça
aurait dû être le cas s'il n'y avait pas
eu cette crise russoau-rainienne. Et
donc le projet est gelé. La question
c'est est-ce qu'il va fonctionner un
jour ou est-ce que c'est un gazoduc qui
va rester
sous la Baltique entre la Russie et
l'Allemagne ? La suite de l'histoire le
Montrera. Mais en tout cas, le projet
est joli. Dans ce projet, il y a
évidemment Gazprom et il y a cinq
sociétés européennes. NG dont nous
parlions, l'opérateur gazier historique
sur le marché français, le groupe Chell
que tout le monde connaît, le groupe
autrichien OMV, un groupe énergétique et
deux sociétés allemandes Vinterchal
Uniper.
projet pour l'instant bloqué et il va
pas repartir de de sitôt. Par rapport au
gaz de chiste américain, comme nous
l'avons rappeler tout à l'heure,
ce n'est pas depuis 2022 que la France
et l'Union européenne importent du gaz
de chiste produit aux États-Unis et
transporté à travers l'Atlantique sous
la forme de gaz naturel liquéfié. Cela
remonte à plusieurs années. Donc, il y a
pour la France une contradiction.
Certains pays européens n'ont pas
interdit le gaz de chiste, donc pour
eux, il y a moins de contradiction. Mais
pour la France qui dit "On veut pas de
gaz de chisse, c'est nous on veut pas de
pétrole de chiste, on veut pas de
fracturation hydraulique mais on en
apporte des États-Unis, ça pose
évidemment un petit problème de
cohérence politique de base. Mais dans
la situation actuelle, comme la priorité
c'est que fait-on si demain l'Europe
devait manquer de pétrole et du gaz
russe ? Et que fait-on pour le moyen
terme avec une Union européenne qui
affiche l'ambition de vouloir se passer
à moyen terme du pétrole et le gaz russe
? Donc on va en chercher partout
ailleurs dans le monde et il est
difficile dans cette perspective là de
négliger les États-Unis premier
producteur mondial de pétrole, premier
producteur mondial de gass nature. On va
en chercher effectivement sauf chez nous
puisque la loi de 2011 qui interdit la
fracturation hydraulique nécessaire pour
la production de pétrole et de gaz
n'interdisait pas des recherches à but
scientifiques. Cela n'a pour essayer de
voir un petit peu le potentiel du
territoire français, du sous-sol
français. cette disposition n'a jamais
été appliquée. Donc effectivement, on
reste avec un point d'interrogation sur
le potentiel français qui n'est pas
gigantesque mais qui pourrait être
significatif. Mais là encore, il faut
parler au conditionnel.
Peut-être plus en pétrole d'ailleurs
qu'en gaz. Question question
plus en gaz. Que pensent-il du projet ?
Alors, je ne connaissais pas ce projet.
EACOP, ça c'est cré Icop.
E A C O P de totale énergie avec des
oléoducs chauffés sur 1446 km avec de
nombreuses réserves naturelles et qui
menace de nombreuses espèces animales
déjà menacées et des populations
humaines autochtones
chauffé
c'est un c'est un projet pétrolier dont
totale énergie est le chef de fil en
Ouanda et donc le pétrole sera produit
en Ouganda
à partir de 25 et ensuite il y a un
oléoduc qui fera Ouanda, Tanzanie pour
aller jusqu'à l'océan Indien. Et là, les
navires pétroliers, les tankers
viendront chercher ce pétrole pour
l'emmener vers différents marchés dans
le reste du monde. Donc c'est un projet
qui a été lancé récemment par un
consortium dirigé par Total Energie. Et
l'Ouanda qui n'est pas un pays
producteur exportateur de pétrole va
devenir normalement en 2025 un nouveau
pays pétrolier. Nous disions tout à
l'heure que en France, on fait comme si
le pétrole et le gaz n'existe pas alors
que pourtant ça existe. Qu'on pense que
c'est bon ou mauvais, c'est un autre
problème. Mais il faut quand même voir
que ça existe et que c'est deux sources
d'énergie essentielle au niveau mondial.
Le pétrole la première, le gaz naturel
la troisème. Donc c'est pas marginal.
Euh par contre, un certain nombre de
pays qui ont du pétrole
et ou du gaz dans leur sous-sol, eux ont
envie quand même d'en profiter. Donc
dans les prochaines années, plusieurs
pays africains
vont devenir des pays producteurs et
exportateurs de pétrole et ou de gaz
naturel. l'Ouanda pour le pétrole, le
Kenya pour le pétrole, l'Afrique du Sud
pour le pétrole et le gaz, le Sénégal
pour le pétrole et le gaz, la Mauritanie
pour le gaz et ainsi de suite. Donc si
vu de Paris on fait comme si les
hydrocarbures ça n'existe pas dans le
reste du monde transition énergétique ou
pas un pays et un état se dit tiens j'ai
du pétrole ou du gaz ou les deux dans
mon sous-sol c'est peut-être pas très
bon pour la planète mais j'ai quand même
envie d'en profiter parce que je vais
gagner beaucoup d'argent avec ça
et je vais peut-être gagner encore les
élections.
Ça ça peut ça peut aider parfois. Ça
peut aider parfois.
On parle un petit peu du pôle nord du
pôle sud. Ça on est où ? va y avoir des
prospections là-bas, il y a des projets,
c'est toujours des réserves naturelles,
c'est plus des réserves naturelles.
Euh,
il y a l'Arctique au nord et
l'Antarctique au sud.
Merci pour cette précision.
Mais moi, je suis pas colen royal, je
sais où ça se trouve.
Ce que je voulais dire, c'est que il y a
un statut très différent pour l'Arctique
et l'Antarctique par rapport à votre
question. L'Antarctique est couvert par
un traité international. initié par
Michel Recard. Non, je crois alors je
sais pas si non de Non, c'était non
Recard, je crois. Mais ce traité
interdit l'exploitation industrielle.
L'Antarctique c'est la recherche
scientifique. Donc on va pas faire des
trous, des forages pour chercher du
pétrole et de gaz. Ça veut pas dire
qu'il y en a pas. Ça veut dire que c'est
pas possible.
On en fait pour trouver du CO2 qui est
un gaz.
Alors ça c'est oui effectivement. Par
contre, du côté de l'Arctique,
c'est pas des trous, c'est des carottes.
Carotes.
Allez, on arrête les bé. C'est terminé.
Francis,
pour l'Arctique, il y a pas ce même ce
même cette même situation juridique. Il
y a pas cette même contrainte juridique.
Et du côté de l'Arctique, nous avons
plusieurs pays qui depuis des dizaines
d'années
produisent du pétrole et du gaz à partir
de zones Arctiques. États-Unis, Alaska,
le Nord du Canada, la Russie, la
Norvège. Donc au moins quatre pays
producteurs de pétrolet et de gaz en
Arctique depuis des dizaines d'années.
La question c'est est-ce qu'il faut
faire plus ou est-ce qu'il faut faire
moins ? Notamment pour des raisons
environnementales vu le fait que
l'Arctique est évidemment une zone
particulièrement sensible. Pensons à une
marie noire dans l'Arctique. Une marée
noire dans le Gold Mexique, on a connu
ça. C'est pas très bon. C'est jamais bon
une marie noire, mais on est dans une
mer chaude. Ça veut dire que une partie
du pétrole s'évapore et une autre partie
est mangée par des bactéries qui se
nourrissent de pétrole. Mais dans
l'Arctique, c'est pas du tout le même
scénario.
Welou.
Mais pour l'instant, il faut avoir
vraiment en tête que l'Arctique, c'est
une réalité pétrolière et gazère depuis
des dizaines d'années dans quatre pays.
États-Unis, Canada, Russie, Norvège.
Une question d'ailleurs saut du
cocalancer
les couvertures concernant les
couvertures énergétiques des compagnies
aériennes, leur leurs assurances sur le
prix énergétique, ça vous parle, ça vous
parle pas ? Vous voulez développer un
petit peu Francis ?
Euh c'est je tiens à dire
évidemment elle consomme
énormément de carburants. Des carburants
qui pour l'instant sont d'origine
pétrolière. Donc elles sont très
intéressées par l'évolution des prix du
pédrole. Quand ça baisse c'est bon pour
ell quand ça augmente c'est pas bon du
tout. Et donc elles vont chercher en
utilisant des marchés à terme à se
couvrir pour limiter l'impact
potentiellement négatif notamment d'une
hausse des prix du pétrole, donc des
prix des carburants. Ces marchés sont
évidemment intéressants, fourniss une
certaine couverture pour des
utilisateurs industriels comme les
compagnies aériennes. Sauf que ça ça on
peut pas se couvrir si le prix du
pétrole augmente augmente augmente
pendant un temps. Ça n'a qu'un temps. Et
puis ça coûte de plus en plus cher. plus
le prix augmente, plus le coût de la
couverture logiquement sur ces marchés
financiers va être coûteux. Donc c'est
bien euh ça permet de limiter les dégâts
pendant un certain temps, mais si on est
dans une période où le prix du pétrole
augmente augmente augmente pendant x
années, euh marché à terme ou pas,
couverture ou pas, euh tout le monde y
passe hein.
Çaelles ont quand même la couverture de
l'argent magique.
C'est une autre couverture.
Moi, moi je voulais faire parce qu'on
parle compagnie aérienne.
J'ai rencontré un marin pêcheur
ce weekend.
Francis ? pas Francis et Marin Pécha me
raconta un petit peu comment évolué ses
conditions.
Oui,
il a acheté son gazol à 50 centimes.
Aujourd'hui, il le paye 1,50 € le prix x
3.
Ouais. Aujourd'hui, la contrainte, je
suis pas très inquiet pour les
compagnies aériennes même si elles vont
être impactées, mais en fait ce qui va
être impacté, c'est l'agriculteur, le
marin pêcheur, les transporteurs
routiers. Dans ce cas-là, dans certains
cas, c'est plus rentable de partir à la
pêche, hein.
Ah, on fait des calcul économiques pour
un
Et s'il y a pas les poissons plus ce
tarif là, hein.
Et donc et donc c'est ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui, hein. On voit aujourd'hui
en Espagne, on a alors j'ai pas suivi où
on en est, mais on a eu un petit peu un
phénomène de gilet jaune en Espagne
actuellement avec des manifestations
assez importantes qui ont d'ailleurs
abouti à cette baisse aussi en Espagne
du prix du carburant. Mais c'est ce qui
va se passer dans les prochains mois
parce que ces gens-là en fait ils
peuvent plus travailler et ils peuvent
plus vivre. Point final.
Et là et là je vais vous dire notre
président
a eu une idée formidable.
Le le l'achat groupé
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de l'achat
groupé ? Et ensuite il y a d'autres
candidats qui ont une idée aussi
formidable qui est de bloquer le prix.
Bon ils veulent bloquer le prix.
Est-ce que vous avez des
réflexions ou des idées concernant ces
idées formidables de bloquer les prix ou
de d'achat grouper ? Bah
l'achat groupé alors sur le sur le
papier achat groupé, on se dit on va
pouvoir faire des économies d'échelle
puisqu'on va pouvoir payer moins cher.
Bah concrètement parlant sur le prix du
gaz, j'en suis pas certain. Puis le
problème c'est qu'on a beaucoup de
petits acteurs qui achètent du gaz.
C'est pas que NG en fait, c'est aussi un
certain nombre d'acteurs, d'industriels
et cetera. Donc ça ressemble un peu à
une machine à gaz pour un gain a priori
euh à mon avis limité, mais ça permet de
faire des annonces et de dire que on
essaie de de mettre en place des
solutions.
Prix bloqué, bah prix bloqué, c'est un
petit peu ce qu'on fait hein, quand on
entre guillemets, quand on donne 18
centimes, c'est une sorte de prix bloqué
hein. On on bloque 18 centimes plus bas.
Donc c'est l'argent magique.
C'est la bonne nouvelle. C'est ça le
Kana Macron finalement
il a commencé, il a eu en 2018 les
gilets jaunes, il a mis du temps à
trouver l'argent magique. Ça lui a pris
18 mois à trouver 15 milliards et avec
le Covid, il a retrouvé plus facilement
l'argent magique. Puisque là, on parle
de 600 milliards de dettes en plus quand
même pour la France sur cette période.
Juste traverser la rue, hein.
Traverser la rue. Et donc là, ben sur
vous savez, on parle toujours souvent de
cette histoire d'hélicoptère my euh
argent hélicoptère. Ça a commencé un
petit peu avec le Covid. Et puis là, ça
continue avec avec les prix l'énergie et
ça se passe dans tous les pays du monde.
Sauf que le problème c'est que on attise
les braises puisqu'on stimule ou on
empêche la destruction de la demande.
Euh donc ça peut on évite la récession,
ça peut durer un temps, mais on l'a déjà
fait sur l'électricité, il me semble en
fin d'année dernière, on l'a déjà
oublié. il était très fier d'avoir fait
un chèque énergie de 100 € à
à 28 ou 38 millions de 38 millions de
français
38 millions de français donc c'était bah
voilà ça va multiplie par 100 ça fait 4
milliards et les 4 milliards ils les ont
eu en 2 jours. Donc on a quand même
progressé depuis les gilets jaunes mais
là malheureusement à part imprimer de
l'argent et et rouler et et augmenter
notre dette on n pas l'impression qu'ils
aient beaucoup d'autres solutions.
Depuis l'automne 2021, on a donc eu
cette euh ce que le Premier ministre,
monsieur Jean Castex, a appelé le
bouclier tarifaire
euh pour le gaz, l'électricité
qui consiste en fait à bloquer les prix,
hein. Si ce n'était pas le cas, les
Français perraent aujourd'hui gaz et
électricité au moins 40 % plus cher, au
minimum.
Euh il y a eu donc Nicolas l'évoquait la
la prime inflation. Euh il y a eu le
chèque énergie qui a été augmenté.
Ensuite, il y a eu donc tout récemment
euh la baisse la remise des prix des
carburants de 15 centimes par litre. Si
on additionne tout ça euh donc depuis
l'automne 2021, c'estàdire depuis hier,
on est pour l'État français à un coût
d'environ 30 milliards d'euros pour
maintenir les prix de l'énergie à des
niveaux pas trop élevés en sachant pas
combien de temps ça va durer. Donc on
revient à ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
sur la le l'argent magique. Et l'argent
magique effectivement comme l'argent
n'est pas magique, il y a un moment où
il faudra payer l'addition.
mais pas en période électorale bien sûr.
Le
prendre de risque.
La première question sur les achats
groupés euh je pense que ça pourrait euh
alors c'est Nicolas disait avec humour,
c'est une usine à gaz pour parler
effectivement des achats groupés. Mais
c'est c'est vrai, c'est extrêmement
complexe.
J'ai vu que tu navais pas fait exprès,
donc je le soulligne mais non, c'est
très complexe à mettre en en route, ça
je suis d'accord. Euh l'idée, je pense,
vaut la peine d'être creusée au niveau
de l'Union européenne. L'idée, ce serait
par exemple que la Commission européenne
négocie des achats de gaz auprès de pays
exportateurs de gaz au nom de l'Union
européenne.
Euh c'est une idée qui est pas
complètement nouvelle. La Commission
européenne l'avait proposé il y a
quelques années en arrière et à l'époque
réaction des États, ah non souveraineté
nationale, on veut nous-mêmes négocier
ça. Donc mais et donc l'idée a été
remise au placard et là tout d'un coup à
nouveau guerre en Ukraine février 2022
cette idée ressort et tout le monde dit
"Ah finalement c'est peut-être pas une
mauvaise idée". Mais qui dit prégrouper
l'échelle de l'Union européenne dit
aussi harmonisation fiscale,
dit aussi
revenir sur les achats groupés, je
reparle du Covid. En fait,
on a fait des achats groupés pendant le
Covid.
Bien sûr.
Comment ça se passait ? On a acheté du
Pizer qui négociait
euh madame Vlen par texto avec le PDG de
Pfizer. Et a priori, on n pas eu le
meilleur tarif, on a plutôt un tarif
plus élevé que les autres. Donc pour
l'instant les achats groupés en Union
européenne, on l'a peut-être un petit
peu en travers de la gorge. On peut leur
laisser une deuxième chance pour voir
s'ils font mieux. Mais euh Urschula Van
est quand même assez ennuyée puisque
elle est censée RGPD, elle est censée
publier les échanges qu'elle a eu par
texto avec les PDG Pfizer dans le cadre
de son travail et elle refuse de le
faire et c'est pas la première fois
qu'elle a sorte de textoate puisqu'elle
avait eu ça dans en Allemagne dans ses
fonctions précédentes. Donc achat groupé
pour l'instant en Europe sur les
vaccins. Je suis pas sûr que ça nous ait
permis d'avoir le meilleur tarif.
Et la question plus c'est est-ce que son
téléphone était sécurisé ? Hein ?
Après après, on pourrait peut-être
mettre une mission pour MINC à 5
millions et voir ce qu'il va faire.
Ça suffit. Mais je dirais que l'idée je
la rejetterai pas
des achats groupés de gaz au niveau de
de l'Union européenne parce
qu'effectivement
on va voir un producteur exportateur en
disant voilà un pays européen vous
aurait pris tel volume, nous Union
européenne on vous prend tel volume.
Pourquoi pas ? C'est c'est compliqué. Ça
n'a jamais été expérimenté, bien que ça
a été proposé il y a quelques années en
arrière, mais c'est intéressant de voir
comment dans un temps de guerre, pas la
guerre en Europe, mais la guerre en
Ukraine et donc nous sommes tout à côté,
change un certain nombre de perceptions
de perspective des idées qui avaient été
complètement écartées et proposées par
la Commission européenne il y a quelques
années en disant si moi commission je
vais voir Gazprom, je vais voir la
sonatraque, j'aurais un meilleur rapport
de force. Les pays avaient dit non, moi
la France veut négocier, moi l'Italie et
cetera. Et maintenant on y pourquoi pas.
Si tu veux boire un coup, question
internet, je vous sauve. Euh peuvent-ils
nous parler du taux de retour sur
investissement énergétique du pétrole ?
Où en est-on aujourd'hui ? Que se
passera-t-il quand ce taux arrivera un
pour un ? En gros, quand on prend un
baril de pétrole, on en sort combien du
sol ? Quand on sort un baril de pétrole,
on fait combien d'éoliennes avec ? et
j'en passé des meilleurs.
Alors donc c'est le fameux taux de
retour
énergétique. Alors je l'ai en anglais,
c'est le E R O E I crois. Energy return
on invested energy. Il y a une personne
qui regarde ça dans le monde, enfin qui
fait des travaux au sérieux. C'est qui
s'appelle Charles H aux États-Unis.
Ça s'écrit comment ? Charles comme ça se
prononce. Et all H A2 L.
Il y a que lui qui a publié là-dessus
parce que c'est compliqué en fait
notamment de comparer les énergies. Par
contre, on peut comparer le pétrole et
effectivement
il y a alors je pourrais pas dire c'est
peut-être qu'il y a une au début de
l'exploitation du pétrole, on allait
mettre un baril de pétrole, on allait en
récupérer 99. Donc on avait 1% 100 1 %.
Euh et puis au fur et à mesure que les
les que le pétrole est devenu plus
difficile à aller chercher. Donc ça a
diminué peut-être 1 pour 50. Je peux pas
exactement vous dire où on en est
aujourd'hui. Euh donc je veux pas dire
de bêtises mais effectivement ça
diminue. Et le chiffre qui est cité pour
que notre société telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui continue à fonctionner c'est
1 pour 10. Quand on commence à passer
sous la barre de de un pétrole investi
un baril investi 10 baril récupérés,
on peut plus entretenir notre système
macroindustriel et cetera. Et sur les
pétroes
alors il me semble que sur le le pétrole
notamment les sables bitumineux au
Canada on est sous les 1 pour 10 même à
mon avis sous les 1 pour 5. Euh il
semble que sur les biocarburants, c'est
la même chose. Je veux pas dire de
bêtises sur le pétrole de Rochem. Et
puis après, il y a des gens qui
s'amusent à calculer et à comparer euh
éolien, solaire, nucléaire et cetera.
Mais dans ce cas-là, c'est compliqué
parce que on doit comparer un système
équivalent. C'est-à-dire que 1 MW
nucléaire, c'est pas 1 MW solaire. Euh
puisque je peux le produire à n'importe
quel moment, quand je veux, où je veux.
Euh alors que s'il y a pas de soleil,
c'est plus compliqué que le solaire.
Donc il faut que je prenne en compte
tout le système énergétique, le
stockage, les moyens de Donc ce qui est
sûr c'est que ce taux de retour sur
énergie diminue et ce qui correspond un
peu à ce qui se passe sur des réserves
et l'augmentation du prix du pétrole.
Mais effectivement c'est physique et
puis le jour où effectivement on met un
baril pour récupérer un baril, a priori
on fera autre chose.
Euh question, je vais en envoyer deux de
suite. Euh l'hydrogène, le véhicule à
hydrogène, çaen est où ?
Euh l'énergie perpétuelle existe-t-elle
? Oui, s'appelle la politique. Brass
beaucoup d'chaud avec les bras. Euh le
biométhane, les gaz verts, ça en est où
? Est-ce que il y a une solution avec
l'hydrogène ? Une solution avec le
biométhane ? Vous en avez entendu parler
?
Tu j
Alors, l'hydrogène, je vais le garder
juste après parce que c'est un peu plus
long. biogaz, biométhane, ça c'est des
choses qui qui effectivement se
développent. Ça s'est développé beaucoup
en Allemagne d'ailleurs. Beaucoup de
d'agriculteurs sont devenus des
producteurs de gaz avec beaucoup de fit
d'ailleurs
probablement. Sachant que c'est un
pouvoir calorifique 250 fois plus élevé
que le CO2 si je dis pas de bêtises.
Donc c'est pas c'est pas terrible.
Donc ça se passe aujourd'hui. On a des
méthaniseurs
au sein des agriculteurs. Qu'est-ce
qu'ils en font ? En fait, ils peuvent le
réutiliser pour eux aussi pour faire
fonctionner leur leurs voitures
notamment peut-être leur camion, faire
de l'électricité. Donc souvent c'est
consommer localement. Donc ça fait
partie des des solutions qui peuvent
contribuer mais euh le poison est
toujours dans la dose. Donc c'est des
doses qui restent assez limitées plutôt
pour des énergies locales. L'hydrogène
c'est euh c'est la solution à tous nos
problèmes.
Donc enfin
c'est ce que nous vendent beaucoup de
personnes. Excusez-moi. J'ai pas voulu
vous faire peur. J'ai pas voulu vous
faire peur. L'hydrogène,
c'est vu comme beaucoup de En France, on
a un pays de technocrate et donc on aime
bien les solutions technologiques et
donc la technologie de l'hydrogène va
nous permettre de résoudre tous les
problèmes, notamment les voitures. Il
suffit de remplacer un réservoir
d'essence par réservoir d'hydrogène et
le tour est joué. Euh
avec l'obénite aussi.
Alors, l'hydrogène, il peut euh et il y
a des grands plans au niveau européen
sur l'hydrogène parce qu'on aime bien la
croissance verte et en France, nous je
crois qu'on met 8 milliards d'euros 7 ou
8 milliards euh jusqu'à 2030 sur
l'hydrogène pour devenir euh quelque
chose qu'on a pas réussi à faire sur les
panneaux solaires, les éoliennes, les
ordinataires et cetera pour dire le
producteur mondial de notamment
d'électrolyseur. Sachant qu'on a quand
même la Chine en concurrence en face de
nous, ça va pas forcément être facile.
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire avec
l'hydrogène ?
hydrogène, je vous l'ai dit, il sert à
désulfuriser le carburant notamment.
Donc hydrogène vert, on
pourraitulfusurer le carburant avec
l'hydrogène vert. Aujourd'hui, il va
plutôt être utilisé pour décarboner les
processus industriels. Donc il y a la le
déficulfuration du carburant, il y a la
fabrication d'engrais et il y a aussi la
fabrication d'acier dans lequel on
pourrait utiliser de l'hydrogène plutôt
que des fours à gaz ou charbon, je sais
pas quoi. Euh dans le transport, non.
Ça peut arriver si vous habitez à Paris
et que vous prenez un taxi hype, vous
allez pouvoir rouler dans un voiture à
hydrogène. Mais ce sera le seul cas de
figure. Alors, pourquoi est-ce qu'on va
pas retrouver ça dans les voitures ?
Pour trois raisons. La première raison,
c'est que premièrement pour qu' mettre
de l'hydrogène, il faudrait qu'il soit
vert. Aujourd'hui, l'hydrogène 95 %
c'est gaz, pétrole, charbon. C'est comme
l'électricité d'ailleurs, sauf que
l'électricité c'est 80 %. Euh
deuxièmement, parce qu'en fait on n' pas
d'infrastructure de recharge. Quand vous
faites le plein de votre voiture à
essence,
la petite borne où il y a les trois
quatre pistolets à la station essence,
ça coûte 10000 €.
La même pour l'hydrogène, c'est c'est 1
million
100 fois plus cher. Et donc et la
différence avec la voiture électrique,
c'est que la plupart des gens
aujourd'hui ont une prise d'électricité
chez eux mais
la plupart mais ils n'ont pas de prise à
hydrogène. Donc ça veut dire que
l'électricité, la voiture électrique, on
peut couvrir 80 % de nos déplacements du
quotidien quand on a une prise chez soi.
Mais l'hydrogène, il faudra construire
un réseau à la fois sur autoroute et à
la fois chez soi. Donc on parle de 10
milliards d'euros. Alors des milliards
d'euros, on l'engage d'argent magique,
c'est pas beaucoup d'argent mais quand
c'est le privé qui paye euh bah en fait
il y a personne donc ça ne va pas
arriver. Et le troisème problème, c'est
que quand on regarde les rendements
énergétiques sur l'hydrogène et sur une
voiture, en règle générale, si on
compare le rendement d'une voiture à
essence diesel électrique, c'est à peu
près du même ordre de grandeur autour de
20 %. Parce qu'en gros, le moteur soit
il est dans la voiture, soit il est dans
la centrale qui produit l'électricité,
mais il a toujours un rendement de 30 %
quoi qu'il arrive. Euh pour l'hydrogène,
en fait, vous avez vous devez fabriquer
votre électricité parce que c'est un
vecteur d'électricité. Ensuite, vous
devez faire de l'hydrogène. Ensuite,
vous devez compresser l'hydrogène, le
mettre dans votre voiture, le passer
dans une pile à combustible. Bref, à la
fin, il vous reste 10 %. Donc on est un
rendement deux fois moindre par rapport
aux solutions alternatives et en plus vu
qu'aujourd'hui il est fabriqué à partir
de gaz naturel, bah peut-être qu'on peut
mettre directement le gaz naturel dans
la voiture. Alors il est beaucoup
utilisé euh par l'industrie
aéronautique puisque on se dit les
avions c'est pas bien, on va les rendre
vert, ils vont tous voler à l'hydrogène.
Alors ça c'est facile de de dire
rapidement que ça va pas être le cas
parce qu'en gros Ah oui, je je crois que
la blague donc le l'association des des
compagnies aériennes et de l'association
de l'avation mondiale annoncé le zéro
carbone en 2050 ou en 2060, j'ai un
doute mais peut-être 2050. Bon zéro
carbone en 2050, ça veut dire que tous
les avions sont zéro carbone,
il volent plus.
Euh un avion euh je crois qu'un avion ça
dure entre 25 et 25 et 30 ans de durée
de vie.
Ça dépend.
En Russie là, ils vont durer beaucoup
plus longtemps. Donc 25 et 30 ans. Donc
si on veut que remplacer la flotte, bah
il fallait commencer à les vendre il y a
2 ans les avions en hydrogène et a
priori le premier il sera pas là avant
2035. Donc ça à priori ça marche pas. Et
le calcul marrant sur l'hydrogène, c'est
que si on voulait faire voler tous les
avions qui atterrissent et décollent à
Rois Charles de Gaulle, pas en France, à
l'hydrogène, c'est 16 réacteurs
nucléaires et 18000 éoliennes.
Donc là, j'en profite pour rebondir sur
la question internet qui disait quit de
la production d'hydrogène comme
sous-produit des réacteurs nucléaires.
Point d'interrogation envisageable,
anecdotique, pertinent. Donc anecdotique
et et pas envisageable. Alors, il y
avait euh en France
des politiques énergétiques un peu
jusqu'à la fin des années 90 et si notre
parc nucléaire a été développé avec une
technologie américaine avec une licence
Westing House, on avait développé la
génération d'après du nucléaire civil
avec la 4e génération avec Phenniix et
Super Phonix. Et effectivement, une fois
qu'on a cette 4e génération, on on peut
produire de l'hydrogène, il me semble,
par craquage à haute température. Et
donc, c'était ça le plan initial euh de
nos Xmines euh pour l'hydrogène. Sauf
que Dominique Wanet a fermé Super
Phenniix et puis on connaissait on
connaît les connaissances les
conséquences. Ensuite, on allait
développer un truc qui sert à rien,
beaucoup sur traurdimensionné qui
s'appelle le PR.
Et en fait, toutes les compétences sur
les 4e génération sont partie en Inde et
en Chine avec des ingénieurs français.
Donc la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'à priori
d'ici quelques années, peut-être 2030
2040, on pourra acheter notre
technologie made in China.
Peut-être sur ce ce point-là.
al juste concernant biogaz, biométhane,
comme le disait Nicolas, ça peut être un
potentiel intéressant
avec évidemment c'est un calendrier qui
n'est pas de court terme, de moyen et de
long terme. Ça peut monter en puissance
notamment à un niveau local, à un niveau
régional. Euh cela dit, il faut pas
oublier que en matière d'énergie euh il
y a les raisonnements
technico-économiques qui sont importants
mais qui ne sont jamais suffisants. Euh
il y a aussi des problèmes
d'acceptabilité sociale et on commence à
voir notamment dans un pays comme la
Francein les méthaniseurs,
tout le monde dans le voisinage n'est
pas forcément toujours réjoui. Donc
c'est un petit problème pour l'instant
parce que c'est pas important. Mais il
faut aussi avoir ça en tête. C'est pas
aussi évident de dire voilà, on va en
mettre partout. Euh sur l'hydrogène euh
les points soulignés par Nicolas sont
extrêmement importants par rapport aux
contraintes.
Euh
cependant euh on constate aujourd'hui
qu'un certain nombre de grands acteurs
étatiques et non étatiques entreprises
veulent être dans la course. Ça ne veut
pas dire que cette course qui est un
paris pour pour une part
sera gagné.
Et en tout cas, il y aura pas autant de
gagnants que tous ceux qui sont sur la
ligne de départ parce qu'il y en a
beaucoup.
On voit de grands acteurs énergétiques,
de grandes compagnies pétrolières qui se
disent dans notre portefeuille
d'activité, puisqu'on a des compagnies
pétrolières aujourd'hui qui nous disent
notamment en Europe, nous allons devenir
des acteurs énergétiques.
On ne va pas abandonner le pétrole et le
gaz mais on va ajouter les
renouvelables, l'électricité. C'est le
cas de Total énergie notamment, mais pas
uniquement de Chelle, de BP, de en
Italie et on veut aussi s'intéresser à
l'hydrogène. Bon, donc il y a un intérêt
de pas mal de monde et au niveau des
États certains on parlait tout à l'heure
de Nicolas, on parlait du plan hydrogène
France, France-Allemagne et cetera de
des projets extrêmement ambitieux. Et
puis on a de l'autre côté de la
Méditerranée
des pays au Maghreb, par exemple
Algérie, Maroc qui se disent si on se
positionnait dans le long terme
évidemment comme des producteurs et
exportateurs d'hydrogène pour le marché
européen en profitant évidemment de
alors l'hydrogène vert produit par
exemple par l'énergie solaire
plus abondante, le soleil est partout
mais évidemment le rayonnement n'est pas
tout à fait le même en Algérie au Maroc
qu'en Suède par exemple et l'Allemagne
est en train de négocier avec Maroc,
Algérie pour voir ce qui pourrait se
faire. le Moyen-Orient, certains pays du
Moyen-Orient dont Arabie Saoudite, Emmir
Arabe unie, grand producteur exportateur
de pétrole et parfois aussi un peu de
gaz mais surtout de pétrole se disent
"Mais moi, avec les avantages que j'ai
euh le rayonnement solaire, euh
l'espace, l'argent que génère mes
activités pétrolières et gazières, donc
j'ai plein de revenus, je vais pouvoir
investir pour me positionner à terme
comme un fournisseur d'hydrogène." Donc
ce que je voulais dire c'est que voilà,
on constate qu'à Toro a raison et en
dépit de tous les éléments importants
technique économique souligné juste par
Nicolas, on est arrivé à un moment où
plusieurs grands acteurs énergétiques,
soit étatiques, soit non étatiqu se
disent "Je pense que l'hydrogène, je
veux être dans la course, je veux voir
et pour ça je peux pas simplement mettre
1 €. Il faut que j'investisse des sommes
extrêmement importantes en espérant que
ça marchera pour moi plus que pour mes
concurrents. Réponse dans non pas
quelques années qui viennent mais dans
les décennies à venir.
Vous jouez au poker ?
Non mais quand on s'intéresse à la
géopolitique
euh on est bien obligé de s'intéresser à
une gigantesque partie de poker menteur
à l'échelle mondiale.
Question internet. Que pensez-vous du
développement des réacteurs à sel fondu
au torium
où la Chine investit massivement ? Ben
ça c'est la 4e génération. Donc c'est ce
que nous il me semble on avait essayé de
faire avec Super Phenniix. Je suis pas
le spécialiste technique des générations
de nucléaires, mais c'est cette 4e
génération que nos écolos nous ont fait
fermer. C'était un projet de gentil avec
les les écologistes.
C'était un premier un projet de je parle
du parti écologiste parce qu'on est tous
écologistes, on est tous écolo mais on s
on s'identifie pas forcément à ces
gens-là.
Et donc bah oui, non mais c'est la bonne
nouvelle et qu'ils aillent rapidement.
Ils ont déjà plusieurs EPR, il me semble
ils sont allés plus vite que nous sur le
PR. Ils vont faire cette 4e génération,
on pourra leur acheter le réacteur
nucléaire et avec un peu de chance, ils
nous fourniront toutes les voitures
électriques qui vont avec. Comme ça, on
pourra rouler 100 % in China.
Je vais vous poser pas des questions
mais je vais vous demander de me donner
trois livres à lire et un conseil pour
les jeunes générations. Francis,
alors je sors mon joker pendant que je
réfléchis, je passe la parole à Nicolas.
Un peu de temps. J'en profite pour vous
engueuler.
Comment ça se fait que vous vous avez
pas écrit de bouquin ?
On voudrait un livre.
Manque de manque de temps.
Manque de temps.
Manque de temps. Si je vous trouve un
éditeur qui vous fait un gros chèque
tout de suite pour un bouquin.
Est-ce qu'il pai en baril de pétrole ?
Peut-être en rouble.
Ouais en rouble. Alors je pense que je
vais attendre encore un petit peu de
temps supplémentaire avant d'écrire un
livre. Je fais une blague. Je fais une
blague avec ça. Le fait que la Russie
souhaite être souhaite être payé avec du
rou pour ses matières premières, c'était
pour soutenir sa monnaie. C'était une
manœuvre complètement. C'est ils veulent
le faire pour le gaz. Ils ont sorti ça
de d'un chapeau.
Évidemment, il y a un petit problème,
c'est que les contrats gaziers signés
entre Gazprom et les pays européens
prévoient évidemment la monnaie dans
laquelle on pelle gaz. et nulle part,
c'est écrit rouble, c'est souvent euros
ou dollars. Donc tout d'un coup, le
pouvoir russe peut pas changer un
contrat de façon unilatéral en disant
"Demain, vous payez en rouble." Donc
derrière ce tour de pass-pass, c'est
l'idée de dire qu'on va essayer de faire
remonter le rouble qui s'est beaucoup
affaibli sur les marchés d'échange dans
les dernières semaines, depuis le début
de la guerre et face aux sanctions
occidentales que nous évoquons. Donc
c'est vraiment ça qu'il y a derrière.
Sauf que les Européens disent "Désolé,
nous on a des contrats, on a bien relu
les contrats, on les connaît par cœur.
Relisez-les, regardez nulle part vous
verrez le mot rouble dans ces contrats."
Donc il y a un petit problème là.
Alors, j'ai utilisé mon Jokier Francis
pour pouvoir avoir trois livres.
Nicolas,
euh moi je suis toujours un peu
classique sur les livres parce que c'est
un petit peu comme ça que je suis arrivé
dans le monde de l'énergie. J'ai
commencé par le fameux rapport du club
de Rome. Donc nous avons fêté les 50 ans
d'ailleurs cette année Limits to Gross
que je vous conseille si vous parlez
anglais à lire en version originale de
et en anglais. Bon, après, ça a été
traduit en français, ça a été mise à
jour puisque c'est le premier modèle
économique, hein, qui prend en compte le
fait que la terre est ronde et que les
ressources sont pas illimitées. Donc
c'est un modèle systémique.
Modèle systémique. Euh donc ça c'est ça
m'a beaucoup marqué et c'est ça qui est
qui m'a encourageait un petit peu à
m'engager sur ces sujets et à
m'impliquer. Euh mais il donne pas de
solution.
Et donc la suite c'est le rapport c'est
le livre de Philippe Bwix l'âge des lot
qui en fait la suite logique de avec
toutes les solution donc pourrait
s'inspirer nos prochains président et le
troisième c'est plutôt un truc qui n'a
rien à voir et que j'aime bien qui pour
position c'est plutôt personnel
s'appelle les accords toltechte
de la
les quatre accords tooltech et c'est des
choses qui vont vous aider un peu à
vivre mieux les périodes troubl qui vont
arriver.
Ah ouais. Quelle édition ?
4 à Tortoltech. Je pourrais pas dire
exactement les mais je peux vous dire
quels sont les accords qui sont assez
simple et vous pourrez prolonger. Il y
en a quatre. Je vais essayer de m'en
souvenir. Le premier c'est que ta
communication soit parfaite. Le deuxième
ne jamais avoir de préjugés. Le troisème
faire toujours de ton mieux. Et le 4è ne
jamais prendre les choses
personnellement. Un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ou ce
un petit conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Alors, on a eu le pull, on a eu le vélo.
Bah oui, j'aurais pu le faire le vélo
mais non, plutôt aide-toi, le ciel
t'aidera. Je pense qu'on on est dans
faut jamais rien attendre des autres. On
est dans un monde qui a quand même
beaucoup d'opportunités, même si les
contraintes vont arriver.
Et ma femme est entrepreneuse et c'est
vrai que quand elle s'est lancée,
beaucoup de gens l'ont l'ont découragé.
Elle avait un métier confortable. Elle
gagnait bien sa vie. Mais tu vas voir,
ça va être compliqué.
Si vous avez un projet auquel vous
tenez, allez-y à fond, donnez tout ce
que vous avez pour n'avoir aucun regret
et surtout ne vous laissez pas
décourager par vos proches. Allez-y à
fond.
Francis, trois livres, un conseil pour
les jeunes générations.
Alors euh
il y a fort longtemps, mais c'est ce qui
a déterminé mon intérêt pour l'énergie,
euh j'ai lu un livre écrit par un auteur
anglo-saxon dont d'ailleurs le nom
m'échappe, qui a été traduit en français
sous le nom de la guerre du pétrole,
mais on retrouve ça grâce à internet. Et
c'est une histoire mondiale du pétrole.
19e 20e siècle. Alors, pourquoi je parle
de ce livre alors qu'on est au 21e
siècle ? C'est parce que à plusieurs
reprises dans notre échange, nous avons
évoqué le fait que parce que le pétrole
n'apparaît pas forcément comme une
énergie sympathique, certes, c'est pas
vert, on fait parfois comme si ça
n'existe pas. Sauf que c'est essentiel
dans l'histoire mondiale, dans
l'économie mondiale, dans la
géopolitique mondiale. Donc c'est pas
mal de et puis je crois à l'importance
de l'histoire. Euh on ne peut pas euh
voilà comprendre ce que nous vivons et
ce que nous vivrons demain et
après-demain sans euh ces deux
disciplines clé que sont l'histoire et
la géographie. Donc replongeons-nous un
petit peu dans l'histoire du pétrole
pour comprendre tous les enjeux euh quit
ensuite à faire autre chose mais au
moins euh alors 2è livre enfin livre
rapport
c'était Benoît Mafi. C'est ça Mafille ?
Euh non, c'est pas c'est un auteur
anglo-saxon dont le nom m'échappe, mais
en la guerre du pétrole euh sur euh un
moteur de recherche bien connu, on le on
le trouve euh on trouvera le nom de
l'auteur et quand on me l'aura dit, je
dirais bon sang mais c'est bien sûr,
comme l'inspecteur Bourel il y a
certains temps.
Et sur un petit teasing peut-être, il
existe un documentaire qui était passé
sur qui s'appelle la face cachée du
pétrole. Oui.
qui est en deux parties et qui peut déjà
vous apprendre un certain nombre
d'éléments intéressants sur le pétrole,
notamment le fait que les Américains ont
collaboré jusqu'en 42 avec les Allemands
pour faire voler leur aviation en leur
fournissant
les molécules nécessaires pour faire le
pétrole synthétique.
un un rapport euh le rapport publié
annuellement par l'Agenceale de
l'énergie, perspective énergétique
mondiale, en anglais World Energy
Outlook.
Euh
il y a quand on est sur des perspectives
énergétiques à long terme, évidemment,
bon encore une fois, ils n'ont pas de
boucle de cristal, hein, mais c'est une
lecture intéressante euh pour prendre
conscience de certains enjeux
énergétiques mondiaux dans une
perspective de prospective, si je puis
dire.
Euh et puis euh peut-être
et bien
lire quelques rapports de l'OPEP,
l'organisation des pays exportateurs de
pétrole, le département de l'énergie des
États-Unis sur ses perspectives
énergétiques et pétrolières mondiales.
Ce sont de bonnes lectures, tout est
criticable mais en tout cas voilà le
conseil
pour les la jeune génération
et bien je
vais m'appuyer sur un homme extrêmement
célèbre
Jean Jorè
euh rien à voir avec l'énergie he rien à
voir avec nos notre thématique de ce
jour
qui dans un je crois dans un discours au
lycéen
à Albi avait dit aller vers l'idéal en
regardant le réel.
Et je pense queen matière d'énergie
effectivement si on regarde pas le réel,
on va dans le mur. Ce qu'on est
largement en train de faire. Si on ne
regarde que le réel et qu'on ne regarde
pas plus loin, transition énergique et
cetera, on va dans le mur aussi. Donc
réussir à tenir ces deux dimensions là
euh c'est un quelque chose qui dépasse
de loin l'énergie mais qu'on peut aussi
je pense utilement appliquer à l'énergie
et comme c'est Jean Jorè évidemment j'ai
bien envie de citer cet exemple-là ça
nous ramène un siècle en arrière et
votre question porte sur la nouvelle
génération mais je pense que Jean Jorès
a beaucoup de choses à apprendre à
toutes les générations y compris la
nouvelle
Francis on a terriblement envie de vous
lire
Donc il va falloir nous sortir un
bouquin rapidement.
La pression est forte.
Messieurs, merci d'être venu nous voir
ce soir. Merci encore. Bonne soirée.
Merci beaucoup.
[Musique]
เฮ